j'espère que ça marche cette fois ci
normalement ça devrait marcher
peut-être tu sais ce que je dis toujours
alexis comment ça marchait pas
normalement il vaut mieux arrêter
relancer mais en fait non ça me tue pas
alors il toujours ça veuille toujours à
temps ce qu'on va faire c'est que j'ai
essayé d'arrêter le partage d'écran pour
le moment et au cas où je vais t'envoyer
sur le truc direct pour que tu puisse
regarder les parties en direct
peut-être que ça parle maintenant il
vaut mieux arrêter relancer mais en fait
ok on va voir on va voir comme ça bon
pour le moment ça tient sans le partage
d'écran déjà je vais t'envoyer un lien
vers les parties tu vas me dire si tu
peux réussir à suivre
je vais t'expliquer comment faire et
comme ça les internautes pourront la
prendre aussi et puis on essaiera de
remettre le partage d'écran un peu plus
tard parce que sinon en fait si on coupe
trop longtemps et qu'on veut que trop
longtemps les gens vous juste pensé
qu'on fait pas la retransmission live et
donc c'est un peu dommage donc à toi je
vais te montrer comment on fait ça tu
vas sur le lien que vient de m'envoyer
sur skype
ouais donc en fait c'est juste chez ce
point comme d'accord c'est juste le site
est en fait en bas à droite tu vas
pouvoir chercher les joueurs je passais
déjà fait une recherche non du tout
comme ça tu vas apprendre comme ça les
gens sauront aussi au passage comment
suivre pas vraiment on est toujours dans
la première partie a donc ya pas eu de
ouais donc deux coaches aux points
communs du coup du coup tu étais sur la
plate-forme de jeux en fait comme quand
tu vas pour jouer on est d'accord
ouais ouais est en fait en bas à droite
normalement
tu peux cliquer il ya un espèce de
podium avec les cris les meilleurs
joueurs faille c'est pas écrit c'est un
espèce de podium c'est que si tu amènes
la souris dessus qui aura écrit les
meilleurs joueurs podium à coeur joie
[Musique]
le coach estime annoncé sa non non non
vraiment que tu sois sur l'endroit où tu
joues comme comme si tu vas pour jouer
en fait comme si tu es sur le sur la
plaine de jeux auxquels je ne peins
comme si tu allais faire une partie en
fait ouais en direct donc tu as un
podium en effet icarus ce soir voilà il
faut que tu suivi car eu en fait faut
que tu cliques sur son pseudo
ouais je clique et que tu écrives sûr
c'est que et 1 il ya un truc poursuivre
ça doit être un face c'est un petit
bonhomme avec une flèche vers lui en
fait si tu passes sur sur chaque branche
je suis ok la voix dans la partie ok
très bien
bon on va faire comme au début et puis
après quand il y aura une petite pause
on essaiera de refaire le partage
d'écran voilà ça marche du coup les gens
me voient la webcam quand même pouvoir
on voit la webcam on voit tout pareil
enfin tout est bon en fait ok le son est
bon la webcam est bon tout est bon vu ce
nom que tu peux pas voir les flèches que
je fais quand je fais les flèches
habituellement ses preuves mais tu
commences a été expérimenté donc tu
disais que c'était 12 cents maintenant
12 130 même up super 8 la wii dans ce
fait qu'il respecte ok il reste pas
beaucoup de secondes et tu vois là la
position hyper hyper fermez là tu vois
les pions ils sont tous les ans face en
face des autres
ouais je vois ça et du coup
du coup c'est une position ferme est
difficile de passer mais là ça va se
jouer ça va se jouer à la souris dans
quoi je disais avant condé marque hikaru
était gros favoris du match
ouais on en avait déjà parlé je sais pas
si on a commenté avec toi le dernier
match des quarts ou non pas ma
connaissance on n'a pas fait une
fourchette la veille avait la tour ah
merde j'avais pu défense et est donc
quoi hikaru c'est censé être un des
meilleurs joueurs sur internet un des
tous meilleurs mais l'année dernière
magnus l'avait battue en finale de la
compétition
en même temps ce magnum donc on savait
pas si tu vas avant il n'avait jamais
joué l'un contre l'autre en ligne et on
savait pas qui était le meilleur en
ligne s'étaient tus et d'arrêter bullet
les trucs des machins c'était magnus qui
était plus fort c'était hikaru et
maintenant on sait que c'est magnus mais
mais ça n'empêche pas qu'il est censé
être numéro 2 mondial et pour le monde
enfin sur internet en tout cas et il a
perdu la première partie donc c'est un
peu une bonne nouvelle pour nous je
pense
alexis on est plutôt pour que fabiano
gagnant fait d'accord 20 ce plus
favorable en faveur du coeur rue là pour
lancer en ce sens dans la peau moment il
ya 1 0 pour fabiano mais il car où ils
les gros favoris du match voit ce soir
et comme c'est le meilleur joueur en une
minute en bullet il est même un poil
plus fort que magnus au même niveau
enfin c'est difficile de les départager
mais en gros il devrait beaucoup scoré
dans la dans la dernière demi heure
dans la demi-heure où il joue un
puissant d'accord ok donc dans notre
intérêt à nous en tant que spectateur
sait que fabiano arrive si tu veux à +3
avant les bullet et puis tu vois ça se
joue dans la dernière demi heure à
savoir sicav ou va pouvoir remonter quoi
ouais ouais bah ce serait bien que ce
soit un petit peu serré quand même quoi
et de suspense 0
voilà donc fabiano c'est un joueur
d'origine italienne en fait hockey qui a
changé de mains qui jouaient pour
l'italie et qui a changé deux nations
entre guillemets qui m'annonce joue pour
les états unis mais tu as beau aventure
ça ouais aux échecs tu as le droit de
changer de pays et de jouer pour de
changer de l'équipe nationale ah ouais
bon foot quoi ouais je crois que si tu
as joué en adulte dans une équipe n'a
plus droit à prêt de changer je pense
sida a bon si tu as joué en jeunes je
crois en moins de 18 ans pourtant il ya
des clubs qui rachète de des joueurs il
me semble qu'ils sont pas deux pays non
mais des clubs mais pas les équipes
nationales ah ouais ok mais en fait
fabien non lui fait un vrai faux procès
parce qu'en fait ce qui se passe c'est
que avec ques les sauces et un autre
joueur qui a fait la même chose mais je
voyais les philippins et l'huile est
vraiment 0% américain sauts et les etats
unis l'ont pris et maintenant ils jouent
pour les états unis et il vit aux états
unis tout ça mais le truc c'est que
fabien est en fait oui il est né aux
états unis et ils avaient la double
nationalité depuis depuis gamin en fait
ce qu'il a vécu les dix premières années
de sa vie je crois à new york
bah ouais d'accord au club ont donc tu
vois c'est pas vraiment le mec il faut
pas % fin tu commences c'est pas la mort
mais ouais je vois c'est pas genre il
n'a pas été achetée tu voyais pas dit tu
deviens américain donc c'est fabiano
donc il est italo américain on va dire
ça comme ça ou américano italien fait
pas comme tu préfère pas trop important
tu t'en fous complètement
non mais bon j'ai compris le principal
quoi du coup moins ici fut d'origine
italienne donc si tu veux je comprends
mieux pourquoi te pour fabiano là au
mieux les trucs way et wat et autres
nationalités enfin j'ai l'impression que
tu as toutes les nationalités russe
français et italiens puis de par sa voix
russe si je prends un maximum de
nationalité pour être bien dans les
matches en fait c'est ça tu as toujours
quelqu'un pour qui
je vois le truc est pour la peine russe
en fait c'est juste que j'ai vécu mes
mais italien s'est vraiment enfin j'ai
vraiment une grande partie de ma famille
vient de là bas
et comme d'autres gens dans le sud est
comme vous pouvez joindre le sud est
ce n'est pas loin canet et l'italie ccc
60 kilomètres ça à côté et donc la
deuxième partie deuxième partie qu'est
ce que tu en penses pour le moment la
première vue bah je dirais que les noirs
ont plus développé leurs pièces non oui
plus d espace pour l'instant les blancs
sont un peu plus rester à l'e3 j'ai
l'impression enfin là quand on voit
l'attroupement avec les tours et la
reine et le cavalier au même endroit ils
sont plus sur la défensive j'ai
l'impression et donc il ya ce trou d'air
ça va faire du bien à non il continue à
jouer mais ça aurait pu faire annuler
donc tu as en lactation
ouais tu as acquis est plutôt positif
pour les plans mais le truc négatif pour
les noirs tu as et la structure de pions
tu voyages hélas de plus en double et la
pile
donc tu as et un peu comment dire
c'est un peu une balance si tu veux
c'est genre les blancs ils ont les noirs
ils avaient un peu un avantage de 2
centralisation des pièces plus avancée
mais en contrepartie ils ont des pions
doublé donc tu restes un jour cette
histoire de balance après c'est souvent
difficile de juger qui est mieux ou
moins bien tu vois c'est évident mais la
fav hikaru là il a bien placé sa tour on
le 4 tu vois il est bien et puis
peut-être prendre la colonne ouverte en
mettant ses pièces sur la colonne e mais
le problème c'est le pion à f/5 qui a
attaqué par la tourache 5 et la dame
dessins que tu vois ce pion au f5 il
n'est pas évident à défendre mobilise
des pièces non non ça devrait se diriger
vers une justice toi petit à petit je
pense ouais
je pense pas que l'un ou l'autre
entreprennent faut faire gaffe aussi
pour les blancs tu as à la casse j'ai de
la tour et la dame qui attaque sur g2 si
la dame blanche s'en va ça pourrait
faire maths
faut faire gaffe mais les classes et
combien fabiano d'en haut niveau et
l'eau classement elo dans la vraie vie
tu veux dire ouais
dans la vraie vie je vais dire ça tu
pour te donner le truc il est de 1700
chess il est au dessus de 1800 donc il
est je vais dire exactement parce que ça
change souvent les places en ce moment à
haut niveau celui qui est des partis
soient à jouer pour le moment caruana il
est numéro 4 mondial est il à 2799 ah
oui le numéro 4 way et nakano quand il
est numéro 10 il à 2780 forcément qu'il
soit plus fort sur internet d'une si
grande différence entre internet la
voirie aux échecs
c'est pas les mêmes cadences sur
internet c'est plutôt du bliss des
parties très rapide sur internet c'est
plutôt du long programme double ici tu
peux aussi en faire dans la vraie vie le
mans ouais
oui oui mais caruana il n'est pas réputé
comme être que pour être un excellent
beats heures en bliss attends je vais
aller regarder
du coup j'ai fermé je vais te dire son
classement blitz je retourne sur le site
en blitz caruana il est 2728 et hikaru
les 2857 away c5 bon chacun ses
spécialités après c'est rare qu'il est
si gros écart de niveau entre deux
cadence
entre deux cadencés juste que hikaru il
se trouve que l'huile et
ultraspécialisés en vite soins
spécialisés et les ultra forts en blitz
et de son côté fabiano il est réputé
pour être assez mauvais en beats par
rapport à son niveau enfin tu as mauvais
tout est relatif un tatouage veut pas
dire qu'ils font mal envie de six mille
fois que fort que moi ouais par rapport
aux mecs de son niveau
il écarte ok bon après c'est plus
gratifiant de savoir jouer de savoir
mieux joué au parti est longue comme tu
m'as jeudi à tous les gros titres se
joue en partie donc en fait oui c'est ça
donc après le blitz ça c'est plus pour
le fun quoi ça puis bon ça reprend un
peu de d'importance à ça prend un peu
d'importance là depuis quelques années
puisque c'est un peu plus télégénique
donc il ya plus de tournois en blitz et
tout ça mais bon enfin c'est ça reste
très mineures comme ça après un beau
tennis le simple et le double si tu veux
ouais si tu es bon en double c'est cool
mais s'en fiche un peu quoi bon mais là
cette finale
intéressant ça avance quand même s'il
reste pas bloqué sur leurs positions tu
vois c'est le roi de fabiano qui est
hyper important ici parce qu'il est en
train d'aller s'en prendre aux pions tu
vois c'est comme s'ils jouent avec une
pièce de plus il a live asthme et en c3
et puis après il va les bouffer un
parent va les prendre la base de la
chaîne et il peut il veut retirer la
racine en fait et aller les chercher
apple peut rien faire là enfin il peut
prendre les autres pions aussi de son
côté quoi mais bon truc c'est que
regarde là maintenant quand il prend un
bain ici s'ils défendent qui ont b3 et
du coup le roi il peut plus faire la
cueillette il peut prendre des 3 lanes
enfin c'est ce qu'il va faire d'ailleurs
je penserai ouais mais bon il faut pas
les prendre soin il voulait faire
prendre b3 et 1,4 en fait il voulait en
chopper 2 bah du coup il va peut-être
faire non je pense c'est pas faut qu'il
fasse gaffe même avec les noirs parce
que la tour adverse soit elle va pouvoir
venir en b5 et il attaquera les pions c5
et a5 avec les blancs non
alors à qui le monde sicard aurait dû
jouer ces quatre avant tout reprend g7 a
tant que reculer pour répondre le prends
qui faisait ses quatre échecs juste pour
te répondre 20 20 peut-être le roy
revenait en d6 et y défendent et le pion
c7 et hikaru je pense qu'il avait
calculé jusque là jusqu'à pour qu'on
décide je pensais les quelques jusqu'à
cette position et il a vu qu'il y avait
pas trop de danger parce que la tour
revenait à temps pour défendre le plan b
3 du coup il a un plan plus la picao ya
un flot de plus et en plus tu vois il a
les pions qui sont qui font deux îlots
de pions blancs à la noire ils font
trois îlots wire n'ai aucun qui se
protège pour les noirs
mais alors où le pied plus actifs qui va
peut-être sauvé le sauver le truc du
coup il va mettre sa tour en b 6
normalement voilà c'est passé de 1800
ouais enfin bon je pense qu'il ya de la
marge
d'ici là tu vas y a un truc pas mal
qu'est en train de faire hikaru c'est
que son pion h4 en fait qui est en train
de faire ça bien au pardon son fion h4
qui bloque les pions g2 et h3 si bien
que si le pion g avance il se fait
manger en fait un prise un passant il
aurait pu mettre sa tour en b5 là plutôt
non pour avoir appris leur a pris son
pion non j'ai rien dis ouais puis la
tour la lampe est le roi de chercher le
pion en h4
ça va être ça va être la course
ils vont envoyer les deux leurs pions
donc allait bien on vous envoie le pion
à l'ena l'on voit le pion c'est là on
mail pour ans et deux parce que sinon
ils auraient pu faire un échec mais il
s'est fait avoir je crois qu'il a
déconné à à blandonnet ouais parce qu'il
aurait perdue qui ont ces quatre sur
échec elles purent h 4 s'est passé mais
en gros il a fait une
il a fait une erreur de jugement
il reste du temps en plus ça aurait pu
comme le temps de réfléchir voilà mais
c'est ça le problème contre hikaru en
fait c'est que très souvent des
positions compliquées comme ça qui sont
proches d'être nul ils les jouent ils
voient toutes les petites magouilles
tactique qui peuvent exister dans la
position en fait tu as tous les pièges
tous les petits trucs
il les voit plus vite que l'éclair et
c'est ça la difficulté dans un match de
3h30 contre contre lui c'est que
petit à petit en fait tu fatigues ils
tendent des pièges 80 des pièges au
début du match
bon tu t'en sors tu les vois et tout ça
mais au fur et à mesure tut tut tut tut
ce quoi ouais je sur l'endurance
ouais aussi et c'est aussi ça son
problème contre 40 cents et carlson en
fait et encore plus endurant que lui
enfin ça le dérange pas lu les petits
pièges
donc il a beau lui avoir tenté des
pièges des pièges des pièges bien au
final car ça n'a rien de dérangeant
j'avais l'impression plus fort j'avais
lu d'ailleurs dans le livre la de maxime
a sorti quand il y à un chapitre sur le
carlton
oui par ac de lui ai dit que justement
vu qu'il est super fort les autres en
face de lui au spa faire à des positions
enfin je n'ose pas attaquer presque et
donc au final ils l'utilisent à son
avantage après c'est normal
oui mais en fait quand tu es plus fort
ça ne fait qu augmenter en fait parce
que tu es plus confiant que les autres
et ça ça te redonne en plus un double
avantage en fait c'est vrai voilà établi
de maxime bah ouais c'est cool
moi j'ai appris à certains trucs sympas
sur les sur les sur le haut niveau
ouais ouais ouais en fait ils essayent
de casser beaucoup de préjugés en fait
c'est surtout ça le préjugé sur les
joueurs d'échecs qu'il essaye de casser
un par un ce à quoi on est tous humains
bah moi je le savais déjà enfin je ne
lis pas avec ma vidéo sur les échecs
j'ai essayé aussi de cacher de casser
par dans ce genre de préjugés très
compliqué ce dont tu as she n'est pas
des humains dans un autre monde
que alors qu'en fait non enfin tout le
monde joue pour se marrer en fait à tous
niveaux d'ailleurs mais bon il ya
beaucoup de préjugés sur sur les échecs
mais allait bien ta vidéo sur enfin on a
déjà parlé mais je recommande à tout le
monde tous les gens qui sont dans le
chat ou saas ils n'ont pas encore vu ça
vaut le coup la vidéo que tu avais fait
sûr sur youtube sur comment ça elle
commence à d'ailleurs maintenant non
même bien plus d'un an
ça doit faire deux ans je pense même
l'avait vu sur grand écran
combien de temps à faire une vidéo sur
les échecs à un max de temps parce que
j'avais regardé tous les documentaires
avant j'avais regardé tous les films
avant parce que je prenais aussi
quelques extraits de films au passage
par exemple pour les fameux moment où
ils font les échecs s'enrichit en face
la whey partie à la vague voilà je
cherchais le mans donc là dans ces
moments là j'avais pris pas mal
d'extraits de films ou à les acteurs
faisait des partis à l'aveuglé est ce
qui est drôle justement c'est que
j'avais à la fin de cette vidéo là
j'avais j'avais parlé de cinq films qui
m'avait plu qui concernait les échecs et
dans ce top 5 entre guillemets il y
avait le film c'était le tournoi
voilà enfin là où fabien attendez quoi
justement après voilà on se rend compte
et je rencontre en même temps tu as bien
au passage et il a tourné dedans c'est
drôle et c'est d'ailleurs c'est assez
drôle parce que je les revues ya pas
longtemps le tournoi j'avais envie comme
ça et il ya un moment il ya une scène où
on voit maxime vachier lagrave en fait
quand il quand l'acteur principal
collecteur principal fait une partie à
l'aveuglé on voit maxime passer à un
moment marqué en fait mais ils passent
comme un acteur
en acteurs figurants quoi ouais en fait
durant en france et 1 une des personnes
qui perd au parti à l aveugle contre
l'acteur principal qui est censé être le
champion du monde voilà ouais ya des
hommes a fait rire parce que on le voit
passer avec son grand sourire il a perdu
contre lui perforce que ça fait toujours
flipper les joueurs d'échecs en vrai de
se faire défoncer par un gamin ah bah
ouais nouvelle génération qui prend le
relais un gamin de 13 ans il en passe
pas si bien devenir grand maître ou
s'ils lui manque encore une norme pour
devenir grand maître mais en gros il
gamin il a 13 ans et 10 mois est en fait
il est déjà beaucoup plus fort que moi
bah c'était pas carlson qui avait battu
kasparov nom qui avait fait une nulle
avec kasparov à 13 ans 14 mais comment
il se faisait il se faisait chier à un
moment dans la partie c'est parti à se
dégourdir les jambes et aux barres et
ouais bah ça je vais partager dans ma
vidéo par exemple moment là c'était
marrant ouais ouais ouais parce qu'il
avait une partie sur est ce que les
joueurs d'échecs sont tous fous
la réponse est non mais bon quand même
vous vite sur l'exception qui voit puis
on avait un autre aussi qui avait fini à
une sorte dans une prison un hôpital
psychiatrique pour ses jouets avec dieu
ou un qui lui laissait une pièce d'
avance à chaque fois un truc comme ça
il disait je bats dieu en lui laissant
un tuyau de 1 en un handicap de lampions
mais bon après ça c'est dans tous les
domaines
j'imagine ccif et tout ça ça existe
partout en fait c'est surtout qu'aux
échecs tu étais obligé d'être
paranoïaque à chaque fois sur voir sur
l'échiquier et peut-être qu'après tu
vois ça joue dans la vie réelle quoi te
devient paranoïaque surtout au final tu
te sens devenir paranoïaque
non mais je veux dire qu'on va toujours
décevoir sa porte
afzali ouais on les suit tiens là n'a
rien tout va peut-être paranoïaque chic
et tu vois de connaître toutes les
possibilités
peut-être qu'à la force tu deviens part
directe dans la vraie vie tu vois juste
avoir un truc intéressant
je vais juste pour les internautes qui
veulent comparer juste un jeu d'échec
c'est à dire une seconde de la partie
avait peut-être tout reprend celle
s'inquiétait pas mal pour tripler les
pions ça aurait été une idée est il
enfin sa tour il sacrifier à tours pour
un fou mais il aurait pu pour essayer de
ramener fin il n'a pas fermé pour
essayer de ramener le pion b verser 5 si
tu veux et que les noirs il ya eu 30 ans
y ont passé tête en table mais le truc
c'est que c'est un peu ce dont parlait
maxime par rapport à magnus tu vas dans
le sens où je sais pas si c'était bon
peut-être il l'aurait pas fait c'est
peut-être moi qui hallucine
mais genre contre moi il aurait vraiment
peut-être tenté ça ça l'aurait fait
marrer il s'est dit bon bah toute façon
kevin je le bats dans tous les cas je
vais me faire plaisent tu vois contraint
qu'il a vraiment envie de batterie le
temps de peut-être et contrit qu'un but
qui devient tout de suite plus timorés
quoi après c'est pas mal joué peut-être
que le sacrifice était juste mauvais
tout ça mais c'est juste pour illustrer
ce nom parler c'est ce genre de coups
que tu vas moins tentés web a donc
sacrifié sans le sang des points c'est
ça c'est que tu prends des risques
et comme lemaitre sur le choix quoi et
quand le mec et puis fort tu te dis que
ça va le favoriser parce que plus la
position est complexe plus ça favorise
le joueur le plus fort et donc au lieu
de tenter ce genre de choses tu vas rien
tenter parce que là tu vois hikaru il
fait un blocus sur les cases noires si
tu regardes bien il allait bien il
contre toutes les cases noires tu peux
plus tu vas tu peux pas pousser ses
pions en fait tu arrives à faire les
allers-retours avec son fou il va juste
passer son tour enfin il cherche la
deûle en fête la danseuse a plus ou
moins plus ou moins enfin ok tu as il
est tapi c'est à dire que si tapie dont
je veux dire c'est à dire que si fabiano
ils essayent de gagner évidemment il car
où il essaiera de le contrer mais il va
pas être entreprenant il vas y toi il
tente rien rires ça va faire nul
toute façon toutes les toutes les nuls
tout ce qui laisse le score à égalité
qui ne donne pas davantage à fabiano et
en faveur d'hikaru parce qu'il fera la
différence dans la dernière demi heure
donc pour lui la stratégie de match
aller simple c'est ne pas faim tu arrivé
au 1 + 1 avec maximum de points de
retard et il sait qui pourra leur
remontée après on prête techniquement si
fabiano il est plus fort en partie
longue c'est qui les plus forts en
stratégie entre guillemets non oui il
est plus fort en stratégie du coup les
positions complexes c'est plus à son
avantage complexe mais un peu fermé pas
complexe tactique parce que tu as deux
types de positions complexes tadjeur
complexe parce qu'il ya des pièces
emprise partout et il ya beaucoup de
choses à calculer ça c'est plutôt en
faveur de hikaru est allé position
complexe parce que c'est plus des
concepts stratégiques tu vois à long
terme
et ça ce sera plus en faveur de fabiano
mais le truc c'est qu'aux échecs souvent
quand tu veux forcer le gain ou tu veux
passer ou transformer la position tu as
une petite phase tactique en fait et ça
ça va toujours favorisé hikaru la phase
tactique un concurrent data deux types
de complexité en fait qu stratégique
plus tactique tactique c'est tout ce qui
est fourchette tout ce qui est famille
découverte comme tu en as fait il n'y a
pas si longtemps tu m'as envoyé la photo
je te fier ça c'est tactique tu vois ces
tactiques alors on a maintenant sa
revanche contre newtee taf il a loupé un
nul ça je l'a vu il l'a marqué 20 fois
dans le tchat
t'inquiète pas je les ai pas raté je
regardais pas le chat en fait c est moi
je regarde en même temps une petite
heure je sais pas qui c'est un bailleur
c'est apparemment un mec contre qui tu
as joué au sein du cube heures contre
qui j'ai joué dans l'est dans les vidéos
de tami a pas longtemps en ligne
ouais on joue sur un double un truc
comme ça en fait j'ai pas fait le
rapprochement entre le pseudo du du
multitâche j'étais sur 13 points communs
avec un mec se plaignent ou titoff
non non mais tu vois j'ai été
complètement faussé complètement à la
masse si une partie des jeux sur
internet ya pas longtemps et tout ça ne
serait pas mal de faire le pion aux six
mans ça se calcule parce que
l'ajustement néfastes tactique tu vois
il ya le fou en b2 qui restera en prison
puis 1,6 après les obligés de prendre
avec le pion et puis le choc après ouais
mais il y avait le fou si tu regardes le
fou g7 avant de cavaliers b3 il aurait
pu aller prendre le four b2 qui n'était
pas protégée alors ouais mais après
c'est un choix quoi
doudou cavalli b3 en fait avec l'idée
c'était protéger le fou j'imaginais
maintenant de faire 2 6 maintenant que
le fou que le fougueux et protéger en
fait à ok ah il le problème pas à oui
mais là il peut prendre en passant non
tu peux pas prendre en passant là parce
que le qi des gens réussissent attention
tu pouvais prendre patience et ont pu
éteindre 5 mais elle a déjà dépassé
c'est une finesse de la règle de de la
prise en passant on y reviendra on y
reviendra
tanger pas qu'on prétende et +6 en fait
tu peux pas prendre en passant tu peux
prendre que quand tu es sur la cinquième
rang jeu en passant à oued où ils
passent pas tu vois ce que je veux dire
ouais ok donc ici ici c'est un peu un
peu compliqué ce que tu vois ce pion aux
6 ça peut être une force dans le sens où
ça crée des réseaux de maths
tu vois ça mais le roi le roi noir g8 en
danger parce qu'il ya enfin forcément ça
crée un réseau puisque le pion il
contrôle des casses proche du roi mais
d'un autre côté à long terme
si un jour on enlève les pièces tu vois
si t'enleve et mentalement toutes les
pièces de l'échiquier bas le roi noir il
pourrait faire rager 7 3 et 6 et venir
choper le pion eu six donc ses pions
très avancé comme ça c'est toujours un
double double tranchant pardon ça peut
soit être une force parce que ça permet
d'attaquer sa contrôle des cases et par
exemple là ça te permet de jouer tour 17
donc c'est plutôt une force à ce niveau
là mais si tu réussis pas à l'utiliser
ça peut aussi devenir une faiblesse à
long terme
là j'ai l'impression c'est plutôt une
force pour la peine là il peut lui
prendre son fou un spoil s'il bouge pas
là le fou attaque et le truc c'est que
si tu protèges le fou par daems et 6 jan
aps une recette qui tombe et tu peux pas
te permettre de perdre le premier set
parce que si tu perds le pion aux sept
sélections u16 qui file à dam
ouais c'est pour ceux qui le prend pas
et le prend comme whip rendez vous là
donc il va mettre sa tôt en 18 ans tout
en toute logique après pareil que le
pion 17 ça peut être une force mais on
on peut aussi éventuellement se le faire
choper un tour des huit ça c'est sûr ok
là c'est le cela c'est le bordel en fait
c'est que de la tactique pur c'est très
compliqué du coup ils laissent prendre
son pion à m comme ce qu'il faut qu'ils
bougent la dame donc je pense qu'après
il va pousser le pion à ses 5 il va
mettre le fou en c4 en fait il va vous
il va s'il va donner le pion c'est ouais
pour protéger le pion qui est plus
proche d'autres domaines pour libérer le
la casse ces quatre pour le fou bon
normal mais on peut même pas faire des
français 5 6l foulée cette emprise et il
va mettre le fou ans et 4 mois mais
après il peut mettre son faux en ce 6
aussi protégé par la dame
il va pouvoir il ya le roi qui en échec
le bout juste en fait les trois cases
sont possibles c'est même difficile en
fait soit tu vas y verrait fuite ce qui
vient de faire pour protéger le pion aux
je pense que je ferai partie par là bas
aussi
et en fait je vois pas trop où hikaru
exactement en venir mais je comprends
que c'est hyper dangereux et que t'as
pas du tout envie de jouer ça avec les
noirs en fait construit car ou en tout
cas contre moi tu t'en fiches total en
fait de jouer sa cité fabiano genre en
fait est très heureux si oui la position
est compliqué le mec va faire des
erreurs ok donc il donne le fouet elle
est carrément de la partie là il va en
fait il va aller le maté en force
tu vas voir ça il va manger du foin f1
ça ils auraient pu manger de foin f1
mais en fait il se serait fait prendre
le set et en déduit tu es se serait fait
maths et donc gagner
ok à chaque fois ils vont jamais au bout
et ils savent très bien s'ils ont perdu
ou pas voilà ça va tellement vite en
début de partie à chaque fois ouais mais
ne soit pas impressionné sacem catalan
icaunais c'est sûr connaissent et sur
connaissent tout ça quoi enfin vers par
là ils n'avancent pas l'eau chaude là
tous les coups la table moi qui ai pas
après les ouvertures toujours
impressionnant tu vois on y laisse son
une ouverture sur la défense bon c'est
pas comment ça c'est pas commun mais en
fait il veut profiter du temps gagné tu
vois il un meilleur développement pour
contre-attaquer en force à la loi qui
profites tu vois de son avantage de
développement il va pousser à fond à
l'endroit
c'est ce qu'on appelle la structure de
pions qu'il a avec les pions c'est cette
dé 6,6 et f5 c6 des 5 le 6 f5 pardon les
quatre pions centraux c'est ce qu'on
appelle un stonewall un mur de pierre
parce que le centre est très fermé et
comme le centre est fermé
tu te permets de d'ouvrir le jeu devant
trois en fait d'accord
donc là tu arrives à ramener toutes les
pièces allaient droit tu vas tu vas le
voir on va voir la partie se déroulait
devant nos yeux mais il va ramener du
lourd allen droit tu voir qui va les
voir la dame les tours qui vont arriver
il va pousser comme une brute
normalement
tout le monde se prépare pour l'assaut
après avoir tu fais pas non plus que tu
veux parce que les blancs peuvent aussi
aussi essayé d'ouvrir mais mon petit à
petit normalement ça va aller naviguer à
l'aise roi ouais ils peuvent plus trop
bouger en choses-là falloir à un moment
prendre des pièces qui avait lieu de il
veut peut-être essayer de rentrer sur la
colonne c'est un moment donné ou
peut-être il veut bouger le cavalier en
e1 puis chassé le camelot cavaliers avec
le pion à f3 et à les chasser ce
cavalier ou quatre pour jouer aux cartes
lui même derrière possible grâce au mode
et on dit c'est quoi la différence entre
est indienne et catalan c'est juste deux
ouvertures complètement différente en
fait cela en est une qui avec les blancs
une autre qui avec les noirs et y en a
une c'est une ouverture avec des quatre
des cinq et l'autre avec des quatre
cavaliers f6 donc c'est vraiment
totalement différent
et bien entouré le cavalier blanc 1,5
[Musique]
pour moi et pour faire taire f34 après
tu as ans il y en a qui commence à
prendre une pièce après ça va faire à
l'hécatombe et lyon tous se prendre les
uns les autres c'est possible ça avance
petit à petit truc c'est que son roi et
bien défendu aussi avec les blancs c'est
pas si facile que ça avec les noirs de
même s'il a ramené pas mal de pièces à
libor retraite ou alors c'est pour le
mode plus en bref cet après pour sur les
droits je pense qu'ils anticipent le
fait qu'ils puissent se faire attaquer
par f3 en fait de toute façon donc ils
décident de de l'enlever en fait en
anticipant le moment il joue il va se
faire menacer c'est ça il mérite cette
taille aurait déjà pu depuis longtemps
non ok maintenant ils poussent les
ouvertures que je joue trop à ces
attaques de l'autre côté au final en
fait les blancs jouent allal el dames
les blancs les noirs joua les droits ça
c'est clair mais après le truc c'est que
l'attak noir même qu'ils fassent via
pascal cavaliers f7 qui va revenir vers
g5 il va revenir vers f3 mais bon enfin
pour le monde lui là c'est cavalier
blanc au tour et je vois pas trop là il
peut lui prendre un pion facile là le
pion h4 peuvent pas protéger ben ouais
mais si tu le prends en fait tu vas
comme ce sera un pion doublé qui sera
assez faible tu te feras remanger par la
suite et ut ouvrira la colonne j'ai
c'est que si tu fais j'ai prend h4 il va
te faire quelque chose comme cavalier
trois échecs et après prend f3 il
reprendra avec l'option est du coup
c'est la tour g7 mettra en échec
en fait c'est dommage qu'ils aient que
la case f3 soit protégée parce que
j'avais une bonne fourchette royal là là
elle est bien réelle et protégé par le
fou toute façon le fou tu peux pas le tu
peux pas le dégager
perso je préfère largement les blancs en
fait fin ils attaquent des noirs ça peut
paraître un peu pipeau si tu veux une
fin il a ramené beaucoup de pièces
muffins à la position reste hyper fermé
mais bon quoique il revient aux
cavaliers ont eu quatre maintenant je
sais pas peut-être que je me suis un peu
emballé alors là il peut prendre au
prochain tour le pion en b3 la menace le
pion b3 et son cavalier ans et 5 il est
super bien passé parce qu'il protège
aussi le fou en b 7 mai il carouge joue
super bien ce genre de positions en fait
il est comprend très très bien
généralement
mais le cavalier blanc f4 est très bien
placé quand même à noter parce qu'il
tape sur le pion us is a way est obligé
de le protéger
bon après là il est protégé par trois
pièces donc ça devrait aller bah sinon
il met son faux son cavalier en décèdent
puis après ils attaquent le pion en a eu
cinq à non il est protégé par le fouet
en fait tout est protégé la de partout
en fait sinon il va avec les deux
cavaliers
il met les deux cavaliers puis il y va
plutôt du pion on peut prendre b 6 aussi
d'ailleurs
du coup tu vois ça mais une deuxième une
deuxième attaque sur le pion le 6 à
petit les protéger par trois pièces tu
vois si la tourelle arrivant des 6 un
peu plus tard ça va vite en bas parce
que là il me le faut ensuite squash ils
sont encore protégés
oui c'est sûr mais bon mais bon c'est
hyper compliqué parce que chaque chakra
il prend avec le chou c'est hyper
dangereux voilà il peut il peut mettre
son son cavalier un an mal an parce que
s'ils le maire en f3 après hypotonie
protège plus le pion ans le 6 et le truc
c'est que le roi blanc il est plus
forcément si bien placé enfin le roi
blanc peut se retrouver en danger je
sais pas il peut y avoir des matches du
couloir
elles ont bien dégager l'un je sais pas
vraiment comment il va continuer avec
les blancs n'y a du mal à toucher les
faiblesses noir en fait
dam des cathos qu'il veut s'en prendre
aux pions b6 mais je vais dire un truc
alexis je pense que les blancs sont pas
mal mais je pense que hikaru va gagner
sur cette partie il va un piège ouais je
sens que les lieux resté quelques
secondes il va plus réfléchir et puis
après il car ou apprendre davantage je
vois bien scénario comme ça il met un
peu la pression tout çà il prend un peu
des risques aux six dégarni un peu le
roi dans les deux les deux ont dégarni
droit mais ok la position compliquée
j'aime bien la position de de fabiano je
me répète mais il ya là c'est son truc
peut mettre son rêve 6 après non mais
c'est sûr qu'il est mieux mais je sens
le piège quoi venir
il est un peu bloquée alors fort et
qu'il attaque avec sa tour halaldom la
casa c'est ce qui va faire peut-être
leur garde et le fou il couvre pour le
non mais tu vas voir ouais mais dans ce
cas là il le méro à 2 tu vois ça tours
après menaces pau 1
tu vas voir qu'il va mettre même si sa
position est très mauvaise
d'après moi en tout cas il va trouver un
angle c'est c'est la magie dicaro cell
ce qui fait donc du coup il lui a laissé
un pion la wii plus en plus son roi est
assez mal placé mais bon il a son
cavalier il a son truc tu vas voir
laisse faire la magie alexis laisse
faire la malle c'est disneyland là c'est
le mic apparaître à l'écran pour les
maîtres sont fous en a trop à ce qu'il
soit ouaip tête il va faire x 6 x f1 fou
j'ai 2 tient très bonne idée mater avec
fougue et de tulle et il va faire un
truc comme ça
laisse-toi faire ta ta ta ceinture et
rangera fois ci
voici ses parts à l'elysée de faire
flouer par tous les deux c'est pas mal
c'est assez original mais c'est sûr
qu'il n'a vu mais peut-être qu'il
réfléchit aussi avec des trucs avec le
fou en bessette highway il faut bien ça
depuis le dégage le pian après par
contre celui qu'il lancerait un pion à
j'ai gagné gagné mais ce que veut faire
fourrer farfouiller de mais tu vas voir
c'est de la magie très important de
comprendre que c'est plus des échecs
gens qui pensent regardé une partie
d'échecs se trompe pas c'est david
copperfield autour des 1 il empêche bon
il l'a vu mais jamais en défense la
l'été en attaque depuis tout ce temps sa
phase dam des hits pour tenter le piège
surtout offrant des huit fois f1 et je
pense qu'imad forcé mais donc et food à
elle va bouger son roi on sait pas ce
qui va maintenant y réfléchit à des
solutions a maintenant il faut régler le
problème de la tour bat de quoi avec sa
tour il prend le faux puis après il
prend la tour moi je vois cela comme ça
c'était oui c'est encore rendement on va
voir on va voir moi je vois trop la da
soit la dame arrive en f3 g2 pour mater
soit le foie arrivant en f1 en g2 mais
je vois trop je le vois trop craqué en
fait il va craquer va craquer ok mais
bon il a sacrifié
il va faire réussissent maintenant ouais
après avoir protégé ou là ou là j'avais
pas vu ça à temps c'est super chaud
qu'est ce qui se passe sur fouet phare
maintenant qu'est ce qui se passe sur
fley fin est roi et fuite
c'est la question que je me posais à ok
il aura il va avoir tout reçu huit
échecs roi prend 1,8 et dames français 6
mai ça à faire nul ça va faire nul il va
prendre il va y avoir échec perpétuelle
pas du coup on aura vu qu'à une parade
de trucs parce que l'art est la menace
la faune f1 feuille de match on l'avait
vu du coût arrêtez de vous moquer de
nous dans le tchat
je regarde même plus hot shot in the
troll je vous reçois je regarde plus
malin surtout fois sis au final tu
l'avais en face ne veut pas l'annuler
non mais ils vont ils vont répéter les
coups là il peut pas il peut pas sortir
des échecs de toute façon avec les noirs
pourquoi elle n'utilise pas son poulain
en fait non j'ai pas vu un truc je
trouve que c'est que les noirs ils
menacent sujet de maths en fait
ah mais oui à un couperet il des
thématiques
c'est pour ça qu'en fait ce n'est pas le
temps de ramener le fou en attaque mais
elle était jolie cette idée avec fo f1
infligé deux matches c'était très
original c'était joli ça ça pareil ce
n'est aux vertus reconnues
oui s'appelle comment c'est entre les
systèmes collard c'est un mélange de
plusieurs trucs pas exactement enfin b3
non s'appelle début larsen dan de
mémoire mais après avec le dé 4,3 ça ça
retombe dans l'idée d'un système cole
c'est un espèce de mélange de plusieurs
trucs en terme de non 1 prester
pollution qui existe c'est pas des trucs
hyper théorique note cependant jour
d'avoir laissé le centre aux pions noirs
en fait c'est ce qu'on va amener ci fait
valoir la structure qu'on appelle il va
y avoir un pion qui va reprendre ok
quand tu as deux pions comme ça en d5
ces cinq sur des colonnes ouvert
centrale c'est ce qu'on appelle des
pions pendant ce qui se passe avec les
pions pendant donc c'est cette structure
de pions que tu es en train de voir sur
l'échec des 5 c 5
je répète c'est que c'est une force pour
les noirs près ce qu'ils contrôlent des
cas centrale puis ce sont des pions
centraux mais ils sont sur des colonnes
semi ouverte comme tu vois et les pièces
blanches à devons avoir pas mal de
facilité à les attaquer en fait et les
pions e3 et b3 donc les pions blancs qui
sont devant ils les empêchent d'avancer
en fait en plus en plus il a trois îlots
maintenant c'est ça c'est toujours ce
dont parlait au début du dans la
première partie aux échecs ce tas des
avantages mais tu fait des concessions
pour avoir ces avantages donc d'un côté
talent centre d'un autre côté tu as des
pions faible après bien jouer aux échecs
c'est réussira à faire parler ses
avantages et à cacher ses faiblesses
mais là je pense fois ci c'était assez
bien joué parce que moins il y aura de
prendre pièces sur l'échiquier plus les
pions seront faibles en faire c'est donc
là pour le vent les pieds ne sont pas
encore les pions ne sont pas encore
hyper faible
il affaiblit s'affaiblissent
ah là il prend le cavalier en abscisse
avec son faux puis après avec saddam il
prend à nancy
est ce qu'il aurait repris pour un oui
d'accord moi je voyais qu'il allait le
prendre avec le faux puis comme ça ça ça
permettait de prendre le pion mais en
gros si tu veux ça illustre quand même
pas mal cette variante
mais même si le nord pouvait défendre
mais c'est juste pas mal l'idée que tu
restes tu as beaucoup de mal à bouger
tes pièces avec les noirs parce qu'en
fait tu doit systématiquement défendre
tes pions et c'est un peu la difficulté
quant à ses pions pendant c'est qu'un
conte attaque un pion là tu vas pas
rentrer le fou il vient hop il vient
mettre la pression sur ces 5 et le plus
il est fou et pascal adam derrière
systématiquement un problème avec
l'autre c'est vraiment pas évident à
jouer mais savait à quoi s'attendre il
l'a fait exprès en fait oui oui après
c'est un choix parce que ça ça certaines
qualités quand même d'abord des plombs
comme ça hein t'as un avantage des
espaces quand même puisque tu es pions
il contrôle jusqu'à la 4e range adverse
donc tu as plus d espace est
fondamentalement situent les défends tu
vas pas perdre la partie
ça va juste faire match nul en fait mais
une zone espérait aussi en pousse à un
moment donné faire c4 ou des quatre là
par exemple je recommanderais pas du
tout de le faire mais si tu as envie tu
as tout à fait le droit de faire ces
quatre damphousse et 1 le problème c'est
que ça laissera la case des cas trop
cavalier blanc donc c'est pour ça qu'il
va essayer de les garder de les
maintenir sur ses 5 et des cinq as non
pas ce qu'ils font vraiment que j'aurais
pas recommandé
il a changé structure de pions donc
maintenant il a un pion passé mais il
peut être un peu faible mais il a obtenu
la case d3 reste est peut-être pas mal
joué au final même probablement qu'un
jouet bien remplie nains
donc il a donné la case des quatre qui
restent webber juste prise maman par par
les blancs sont cons ces quatre assez
faible mais il a la case d3 pour son
cavalier une nouvelle fois reims
toujours la même chose tu fait des
concessions mais obtient des choses
caisses des trois ça tu vas pas l'avoir
parce que tu as pris ta pièce et la tour
qui arrive en b1
j'aime bien les blancs perso mais mon et
cavaliers en a quatre ce serait pas mal
non
pour le monde tu peux pas parce que
c'est contrôlé par la dame me 8 et la
torah six hommes j'ai pas vu la dame jeu
[Musique]
à ces drames voilà pour plus que ce soit
en îlots déception mais tu vois qu'ils
karoui laisse pas faire parce que la
case bessin qu'elle est contrôlé trois
fois donc enfin ne veut pas que le pion
que le pion arrivants b5 et qui se
reconnecte en fait il veut laisser le
plan b 6 voilà les contrôler quatre fois
maintenant veut pas du tout les pions se
reconnecte entre en fait il ne laisse
pas faire sinon des cinq des quatre et
ça avance mais bon finalement ben ses
pions pendant ils ont doit être un peu
faibles ils sont bien défendus avec les
blancs on réussit pas vraiment à
s'organiser parce que les blancs ils ont
aussi leurs problèmes
et s'il est noir réussissent à un jour à
ramener un cavalier e 5 e en d3 ce sera
une autre paire de manches en d3 il sera
bien placé ce sera une pieuvre on
appelle ça une pieuvre quand les
calissons sur la 3e au 6e rang j'ai
enfin chez l'adversaire comme ça ce
qu'ils contrôlent beaucoup beaucoup de
cases
tu vois là peut-être que cavalier e 5
c'est un match assez serré en termes de
niveau de jeu après on sent quand même
hikaru qui dans les deux trois moments
un peu chaud s'en est bien sorti ok il
laisse pas faire cavaliers detroit un
hic ou cavaliers et pourquoi il mettrait
pas son cavalier en en b 5
ouais tu peux mais bon ne serait pas sur
un tu vois le jeu il est plutôt centrale
est le roi faudrait pas un peu passé par
b 5 mai pour aller quelque part d'autre
en soit si tu vas en bessin qui sait pas
ce que ça bloquerait les deux pions en
soit si le mes en 2,5
oui mais ils sont déjà bloqués si tu
veux comme ça pour le moment
donc à moins d'avoir une idée derrière
la tête avec cavaliers b52 faire rentrer
la tour en jeu ou quoi ça ce serait une
chose mais le maître en b 5 pour le
mettre en bessin qu il va peut-être le
faire après mais un échange de domme
j'ai rien vu à les supports rapidement
pris à un cavalier 5 bien joué
regarde il veut jouer sur le fou qui
tapait sur le cavaly c3 ok maintenant
l'autre il va attaquer le pion mais je
pense que ça se dirige vers il n'y pas
ce qu'il ya de moins en moins de pièces
sur l'échiquier mais il faut que fabien
en face quand même attention toujours
perdu 40
ski car oui veut ramener son roi vers 4
mais bon ok f5 bien joué et il va
ramener son roi vert aussi ce petit à
petit
à metz le pion à non seulement le
protéger peu avant ce vraiment le pire
il peut avancer l'avancé mais d'un autre
côté il va perdre le pion b6 et du coup
le pion d'hikaru le pion à y va avancer
mais bon là tu vois on est typique dans
le moment tactique tu vois la ccl plus
de la stratégie saas et du calcul pure
et là bon courage à fabiano pendant tout
le match pour pour calculer parce que
hikaru il est insupportable
il va toujours te trouver un piège
toujours du cosip rend le pion ouais
après la rigueur il peut toujours le
prendre avec son cavalier s'ils arrivent
à faire dame en c1 quoi jouer tout
reprend pions j'imagine échanger les
tours et sacrifier son cavalier e 2
contre le pion quand il arrivera en c1
genre échanger les tours ces deux fous
b2 et balancer son pion à et quand tu
fais c1 dames du coup le purin sera
hyper avancé quelque chose comme ça
c'est parce que je me sacrifie
maintenant je pensais qu'ils sacrifient
plus tard celle inverse il fait l
inverse un nom parce qu'il ya sept
points de tactique dans c'est un nom
était dans une autre variante il faire
la courage moi je calcule et une autre
variante j'ai l'impression que ça allait
pour que ça allait aussi bien fait
bouger sauf un
là il peut prendre le pion tranquille là
un ministre ça plutôt prendre le fou en
fait ouais parce que le plus on est
jeune est bien le truc qui va perdre
il va dans ce sens pions nous sommes
quand même pas y en avait deux qui
étaient attaqués en fait j'ai six aussi
été attaqués
du coup là on a deux bouquins hockey et
du coup bon ouais mais tendent des
pièges en fait nous tendre des pièges il
tente d double attaque qui tentent des
trucs et de façon le pion b5 tu pourras
pas le sauver il va aller choper tôt ou
tard les pièces noires sont trop mal
placé
pas mal joué de la part de fabiano il va
il va chercher du contre jeu avec les
échecs par les arrières il va essayer de
faire tout rejet un échec et il veut
essayer de de créer un réseau genre
juste avec les faits chaque fois
seulement méjean retour j'ai un rouage
trois cavaliers f3 et menacera g4 matt
éventuellement voulait créer un réseau
de maths
donc il va faire tourner un échec quand
même je pense et là attention à pas
faire rage 2 puisque ray cavalière trois
rois h3 et du g4 maths j'ai un peu vite
armée pour essayer de
et du coup il va pousser le pion angers
4 fabiano et ça va être hyper chaud non
c'est hyper chaud
le propose le nul il y avait une menace
maths en un coup g4 qui va être changé
et maintenant ça devrait me lève 3
échecs qui a rédigé 5 ça devrait faire
nul a de façon si le roi vent hk tueur
et cavalières 3 6 3 en 1 h 5 tours j'ai
cinq d'or en descente nul
bon j'avais l'impression que les blancs
étaient mieux parti pourtant il a un
petit avantage à un moment donné mais
donc
c'est une belle c'est une supposition
l'a déjà pour la deuxième ou troisième
fois dans le match cette position là
j'ai remarqué j'ai à chaque fois ils
leur font toujours les mêmes d'ouverture
et jouer à haut niveau c'est la
berlinoise c'est une des ouvertures qui
est le plus jouer à haut niveau depuis
quelques années et on se tape de cette
ouverture parfois quand ils font des mac
pour le titre de champion du monde où tu
vois des gros matches il arrive qu'on se
tape la berlinoise
il lui arrivait constate à fleurs cette
fille partie d'affilée genre temps peu
plus après de voir ça en fait en a marre
c'est tout temps la même chose ça se
joue sur des petites finesse de
préparation qui sont absolument
inaccessible au commun des mortels genre
même si tu es un très bon grand maître
il ya des coups que tu ne peux pas
comprendre en fait ça pas bon c'est trop
faim a fait genre moi qui connais bien
plate qui est seconde en 2° tubes dont
qui les seconds en du joueur qui est
genre 8e mondiale en ce moment il arrive
qu'ils passent je sais pas peut-être 30
40 heures sur une position
ah bon show donc toi tu arrives pour
commenter tu vois tu es tout schuss aux
commentaires tu arrives léa position qui
arrive le mec joue un coup ils sont
juste passées de 40 heures dessus tu
vois avec des ordinateurs avec une
équipe parfois ils sont deux ou trois
sur le truc toi tu arrives pour
commenter tu es là bas ok tu vois il a
fait ça ok enfin quoi tu réussis à
expliquer quelques petites idées mais tu
vas jamais comprendre toutes les
finesses derrière et tout ça c'est
impossible c'est trop compliqué c'est
pas un peu dommage de ceux des deux
ordinateurs
ouais enfin c'est obligatoire après tu
as well as ils ont le droit d'en qu'ils
le font mais je trouve que ça c'est un
peu dommage pour les échecs quoi ça tue
un peu le romantisme du jeu mais bon si
tu les utilise pas en fait tu vas tu ne
peux pas en fait tu n'as pas le choix
mais après on peut mais non tu peux tu
peux pas faire autrement oui enfin c'est
pour ça qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
veulent passer au aux échecs random aux
échecs richard gasquet qui choque les
chèques phifer c'est le 960 à j'aime
bien les 960 mais que je connais pas les
ouvertures j'aime bien c'est ce qu'on
appelle les échecs les randos ce que
proposait de faire fischer en fait pour
tuer justement là et les préparations
les ouvertures et pouvoir vraiment jouer
dès le premier coup aux échecs entre
guillemets car il peut y avoir un truc
marrant vrai mais ça marche pas
s'arrêter de si de farnham des six pour
faire d'alger 3 échecs ça ça va te
plaire dame j'ai trois échecs si la dame
arrive en g3 le pion à f2 pourrait pas
la manger
euh tu vois là les blancs ils ont gagné
un pion tout à l'heure en 5 mai partent
pas à leur avantage ce soir enfin je
pense qu objectivement ça doit être pas
mal mais tu te mets quand même dans une
telle galère pour un pion après un pion
ça peut donner la victoire mais enfin tu
sens comment c'est difficile de jouer
avec les blancs laissant soir défense
des bleu et blanc assez sûr pour un
petit pion après ça peut donner la
victoire aussi un pion mais bon dur quoi
virtual flambée ici s'il est bien placé
parce qu'ils coup le pion à f2 avec les
blancs on aimerait pousser le pion à f4
et chasser tu vas prendre de l'espace
chasser les pièces noir et donner de
l'air pour tes pièces pour tes tour tu
as tu pousserez le pion à f4 tu mettrais
la tour en f3 comme ça ça défendrait le
pion des 3 es tu prendrais de l'espace
en fait têtu carrément tu pousserait les
pions pour attaquer il faudrait mettre
ton pu ranger 5 tattoo rage 3 à la dame
orages 5 tu pourrais comme ça a mené une
attaque à long terme en fait avec les
blancs mais le fait que tu puisses pas
bougé le pion à f2 c'est très pénible
en revanche si un jour tu réussis à
faire f 4 ce sera bien mais bon se
recentre du côté droit
en fait il faudrait qu'ils arrivent à
faire bouger la reine pour prendre son
pion en angers 4 presque sacrifices non
non ce serait trop
j'aime bien sacrifier une tour
maintenant non pas à la rue à la rigueur
il mais ça va il met sa tout ranger ses
affaires comme ça la dure quoi et puis
après en plus notre menace mathon un
coût non il y aura les dames qui
s'échangeront et ça donnera une finale
il fait même pas tous hein
en fait il a le temps il le garde
il le garde fou qui veut d'avoir réglé
le problème à l'ale ce qui peut aussi un
moment donné c'est de faire tout
réussissait à les mater sur la colonne h
même pas prendre le pion mais juste
mater
je vois qu'il ya des gens qui parlent
d'une partie de risma touline qui est
assez énorme et allez je vais demander
au chat s'ils veulent une petite
anecdote sur cette partie j'ai une
petite anecdote supplémentaires ah bon
tu ne te là j'ai eu des infos à la sont
fous il est complètement bloqué la whey
s'en fout complètement bloqué son
footing peut-être pas la meilleure sur
le chou restée bloquée tout seul tu vois
il veut où il veut prouver qu'il est
moins fort en stratégie bon après il
peut toujours faire ça tout ranger ses
101 sapa problème oui mais maintenant il
ya le ya le pion f qui pourrait
peut-être venir intervenir
éventuellement avoir bon elle préfère
sacrifier son pion pour raismes et loti
veut pas le truc c'est qu'en fait c'est
ça c'est que lotis mais depuis en d4 et
il a complètement enterrée de fou et
maintenant il va pouvoir pousser f4 tu
vas voir s4 va venir il va il va tout
jouer à l'ailé droite voir que la partie
elle va complètement se retourne et
célébra de koalas la stratégie
complètement changé la complètement ça a
complètement changé la physionomie de la
partie fait eu cinq affaires f4 f5 c'est
les blancs qui vont essayer d'attaquer
le roi
alors la petite anecdote en fait
l'anecdote c'est que en fait risma
touline est passé chez vlad donc mon
copain vlad quelques mois après une
fameuse partie je t'enverrai la vidéo
assez incroyable où il a donné une tour
sur échec est en fête se passe lui
achève là des vagues dit oui partie
exceptionnelle incroyable et tout ça
magnifique ton sacrifice de tours et
l'adonis donc prisma touline qu'on
appelle dans le jargon crise matt hill
diable a donné en fait pas du tout c'est
juste qu'il avait absolument rien vu ils
se retrouvent dans la merde et il a
compris que le seul moyen de tenter
quelque chose s'était donnée la tour sur
échec mais il a plus fait ça par dépit
et pour tenter sa chance que par jenny
en fait donc dans ce coup génial mais
que tout le monde a pensé une conception
génial et tout et tout ben au final
c'était juste ismat qui s'était un peu
raté qui se retrouve dans cette position
qui savait plus trop comment s'en sortir
et qui a décidé de donner la tour donc
voilà pour la petite anecdote comme quoi
ce comme moi c'était un coup de génie tu
vois mais en fait faut pas abandonner
trop tôt comme quoi c'est ça il s'est
dit ok je vais tenter ça leur ait su
plaisait pas du coup il a tenté ça et
puis il se trouve que ça a marché mais
c'était c'était vraiment dû à sa fin du
hasard c'est pas du hasard mais ce
n'était pas prémédité voit la petite
anecdote
bon elle peut prendre le pion en trois
vers eager même aux proches parce que ça
donne ainsi peut-être qu'il peut pousser
après le plomb 1 1 à 5
jusqu'à la dame peut-être après c'est
une question tant parce que est ce que
pendant que tu va pousser les pions tout
ça tu vas pas te faire mater donc c'est
ce qu'on va avoir un c'est intéressant
parce que c'est la question qu'on se
pose en fait c'est ce qu'on peut
impunément prendre le pion à lui je
mettrai une petite pièce sur caruana
dans celle là
les gens qui sont dégoûtés de mon année
âge j'avais à lui proposer ce que la
sacrifier le fou banon mais après ils
attaquent la dame et sa part mais ouais
on qui reprend avec le pion il reprend
après le pion derrière angers 5 ans qui
va prendre la tour angers 6 ha non il
peut même pas il peut même pas prendre
là à temps il peut même regarde à messi
s'il va ou ce qu'il faut a disparu il y
avait plutôt à huy à shrek avec louage
avec le fou je me dis merde non mais
attends c'est quoi ce bordel
parce que là en fait tu regardes il ya
des pions il ya trois pions passé lié à
wall à ce show là il va pouvoir faire
une belle dame peut-être moi qui disais
que je sentais bien fabiano mais c'est
le problème contre hikaru c'est qu'ils
trouvent toujours des trucs comme ça
tout le temps tout le temps tout temps
il est insupportable et en plus c'est
fatigant franchement enfin je rigole pas
quand je dis ça genre physiquement c'est
vraiment difficile quand tu es en face
parce qu'à chaque partie se trouve des
trucs là je pense que fabiano ils
calculent tourache un tour h4 et
tourache un pour aller mater du coup il
fait aussi 100 premiers mais je pense
que dans l'esprit vallée le maté bah
ouais c'est soit il le mat soit l'autre
ils rêvent alors une dame quoi les pions
ils font très peur surtout qu'il y en a
trois alliés quand il y en a deux ils
sont faciles à gérer mais trois c'est
souvent difficile encore qu'il peut
peut-être ramener son silence est
peut-être le pion ses 7 aces qui peut
vraiment le prendre
j'ai passé peut le prendre mais bon il
faut voir et ce qui passe à avance
avance ou la civis et commence à devenir
dangereux fait p 3c 2b 2c fini enfin il
a deux coups de gagner en fait avec les
noirs il va pas les arrêter les pions
c'est sûr il ya même la radio il peut
peut-être faire une dame en premier nom
qui va sacrifier sa tour contre tu vois
ok mais les pions il arrive ça faut
peut-être qu'ils sacrifient le cavalier
dessus et ça mais bon alors qu'est ce
qu'il a fait parce qu'il va défendre aux
qui continue ou la principale arrêté
avec la tour l'autre va prendre le pion
c3 il va bloquer le pion à est
normalement c'est nul il va mettre la
tour en a trois et ça normalement c'est
nul je vois pas comment les noirs
peuvent gagner ça avec son roi il peut
peut-être prendre
ah non on remarque ici à trois contre
trois la loi je sais que c'est gagnant
pour les noirs mais avec un contre-un
j'imagine que c'est nul c'est avait plus
de pions à l'endroit ce serait gagnant
mais là je pense pas que ce soit gagnant
voilà quand même réel cela bien senties
règle non mais il était vraiment mal car
on en fait un moment donné je sais pas
si ça prend des cartes ce qui se passe
c'est sûr qu'à l'étranger 600 premiers à
la dame en fait j'ai peur pour fabiano
après fabiano il est connu pour une
excellente technique est connue pour une
très bonne technique il avait comme
entraîneur notamment jour celle off qui
est un entraîneur très très réputé
soviétique et donc il est réputé pour
être très fort en finale chaque fois
c'est des entraîneurs soviétique
quand un entraîneur soviétique c'est
vrai c'est plutôt bon signe
comme dans le film le tournoi ça c'est
un grand classique des échecs
l'entraîneur soviétique à il peut le
mettre en échec
bon ça sert à rien
[Musique]
non il va peut-être bouger sa tour ou
après le meilleur de chacun roi des 3 c
sur wade 5 et là maintenant je pense y
est allé un peu trop d'endroits valence
4e à temps et ce qui s'est pas fait
avoir et maintenant tour f 7 ou
peut-être tour 17
encore plus fort ça protège le pion il
est en train de se faire avoir et je
pense maintenant autour des 3 ah ouais
comme ça après il peut en extension
jusqu'à dame ku et le roi mais a il le
prend pas et le propre à moi et tu peux
pas faire droit droit des quatre à cause
de tour quatre échecs du coup maintenant
pranger 3 il va garder la tour sur la
colonne eux et c'est fini c'est gagné
oui ou sur l'a31 c'est comme ça aussi
les deux gagnants il a eu du coup ça
fait combien comber mais fantastique 1
c'est la partie iv émis deux ennemis
mais je me demande cette finale avec un
contrat en fait je pensais qu'elle était
nulle
mais c'était joli away clairement a fini
par l'avoir et donc fait mais les partis
sont enfin les parties sont plus serrée
que le score ne le laisse en tant que tu
vois moi parce que chaque fois c'est
toujours au dernier moment que
finalement on allie dénouement avec des
retournements de situation 1 il a une
grosse grosse technique vraiment bien
joué de la part ou le bon vieux pont lu
sénat nous dit chris lowe on n'a pas vu
mais en fait ça arrive ça se serait
terminée en pont lui s'énerve à bixi
faudra que je demande ça à l'occasion de
peut-être comble de ça au point de lui
ses bas du sénat c'est un mec qui a
inventé une technique pour gagner en
finale qui ressemble à un pont et du
coup leur a franchement c'était comme ça
du coup du coup le mec s'appelant lui
sénat
ça fait un pont lucene d'accord ça une
technique qui bat sa date
oui d'accord aux caisses paraissant quoi
et publié un bouquin pour la première
fois de mémoire
là encore des gens dans le chatt voir
wikipedia qui vont me corriger mais je
le bouquin de la doit dater de milieux
fin du xvième siècle et va mais quand
j'avais fait mes recherches seront sur
les échecs que j'avais remarqué qu'en
fait c'étaient les pays à tour de rôle
qu'ils menaient au fil du temps dans
l'histoire des échecs un coup c'était en
italie puis à un moment ça a été la
france paie chaque fois il y avait un
pays est un pays qui mené pendant une
cinquantaine d'années puis après c'était
mes autres à tour de rôle domination
mais surtout un deuxième guerre mondiale
à la guerre froide plutôt pardon oui il
ya les soviétiques tout ça mais parce
que dans l'histoire tu vois quand la
france quand la france était à la pointe
des échecs on n'était pas trop mal
c'étaient les français les britanniques
tout ça le vieux continent
mais tu vois là on a beau avoir un
maxime quai numéro 2 me semble
actuellement on n'en parle pas trop
quand même tu vois mais tu tu sais qu'en
termes de nombre en ce moment c'est
marrant parce que c'est les pays
émergents qui ont beaucoup de joueurs
d'échecs fort qui viennent je parle pour
par la moyenne des forts joueurs un pas
par pas parler par les têtes de tête
d'affiche en fait tu as beaucoup
d'indiens qui sont en train d'arriver de
chinois et moi c'est marrant parce
qu'une nouvelle fois cédé pays des pays
émergents ouais ouais
les maximes personne n'en parle
quasiment dans les médias fin il a fait
une apparition au quotidien chez ruquier
il n'a pas encore fait de 12 questions
avec toi j'attends je renverrai un petit
message un après après le ski là une
grosse grosse échéance la mi novembre sa
démarche je crois le le 14 ou le 15
novembre c'est le tournoi le plus
important de l'année pour lui voit le
tournoi où il se qualifie pour savoir
s'il peut combattre même lieu de ça
c'est le tournoi qualificatif pour le
tournoi qualificatif pour combattre
magnus avec un autre au caire si tu as
un petit peu joué c'est un satellite
pour le pour le satellite quoi j'en
parle justement maxime vendre son livre
qui permettre d'affronter le champion et
qui dit il en parle d'ailleurs de cette
date en 2018 qu'ils espèrent être en
finale pour l'affronter mais apparemment
il l'a déjà battu plusieurs fois et la
met une fois en partie longue et
plusieurs foires à qui doit hélas faut
il a battu en partie longue
enfin il explique dans son livre que
magnus était un peu déconcentré parce
que juste avant il y avait eu à le
meurtre la ddt sur l'île de plusieurs
plusieurs personnes de son pays comment
s'appelle ouais c'était juste le
lendemain vous avez un gars qui avait
tué six ou sept norvégien là je sais pas
mais en tout cas c'était le lendemain
d'une partie d'une partie longue
c'était avant une partie ranspach dont
est apparemment bat maxime lassitude l'a
senti déconcentrer au début de cette
partie et ça a permis d'après son livre
ça lui a permis de l'emporter
la partie s'était pas avant avants
brivistes résistaient bien avant non
c'était peut-être mais bon maintenant
mal est fait malheureusement il ya
tellement d'attentes a maintenant
l'impression tous les jours non réponse
pas du tout le l'endroit pour en parler
mais mais bien par là qu avant qu'on y
avoir un attentat aurait pu le site est
tout de suite parce que y en a il y en
avait 1 tous les quatre ans maintenant
il y en a un tous les deux mois donc on
n'a encore rien il ya deux jours il ya
il ya trois jours à new york j'ai
l'impression que c'est devenu banal non
clairement l'impression faire avant on
aurait parlé on aurait des sous le choc
tout ça maintenant ouais mon nom mais en
fait il ya un truc encore beaucoup plus
gros il ya deux mois à las vegas et tout
donc en fait tu t'en as tu t'en sors
plus quoi c'est devenu trop banal ça
perd en puissance du coup c'était trop à
la mode coiffure et qu'ils arrêtent
mais c'est comme les vidéos tu des fois
ce qui fait moins deux vidéos peut-être
les gens seraient plus content quand on
sort du coup marc webb
pas forcément et oubliez aussi le
parfois internet ça va tellement vite
les stages et remplacé quoi une vidéo
c'est elle est quant à lui en ligne
elle fait le plus de vues sur les deux
premiers jours alors 48 heures et après
c'est comme si c'était déjà des dates et
non démodés avariée à ibos ossun
mais le pire ce que justement là en ce
moment you tube et des menus this plein
de vidéos parce qu'ils ont des problèmes
il sacrifier son fou il veut faire d'un
match 4 échecs comme ça ils sortent de
la menace de la dame et ils vont
encaisser le car a lancé quatre ateliers
déjà tout vu tout le truc c'est que si
la dame arrivée sur la huitième ranger
your et mat
ce qui a le fou qui contrôlent h 7 mai
le cavaly tient la casse des six qui est
hyper importante ce qui n'a pas d'âme
des six du coup qui aurait été pénible
et en plus il menace le fou à 3 mais bon
il va juste bouger le fou et ça ça jouer
mais oui démonétise moi aussi des moyens
tismée vidéo en ce moment même mois ah
ouais ouais ouais deux portiers de choc
ouais ouais indemnity ce très souvent
mais je crois c'est enfin je sais pas
pourquoi mais il me démonétisé une
monétisation mais tu vois le problème
c'est qu'ils démonétise les deux
premiers jours où tu fais le plus de
vues ou tu fais 4 90% de vue
après ces gros gros problème tu vas
enfin moi c'est tellement ridicule
le youtube money ces genres s'assure
mais pour de youtube heures tu vas qui
font qu'ils font tous leur tout leur
argent sur leurs vues et qui ont fondé
millions ces problématiques métiers
d'avenir tu peux pas faire ta vie de ça
parce que les très gros genre squeeze
tous après ces différents mais genre
sinon même si quelqu'un réussit à gagner
juste un smic ou quelque chose comme ça
le truc c'est que youtube aujourd'hui
était populaire demain plus personne te
regarde après demain une autre
plateforme
enfin c'est trop pâle à tabac après
youtube heures c'est un métier d'avenir
mais c'est juste que ça me dit qui est
pas du tout stable financièrement quoi
soit il arrive quelque chose avec
l'algorithme et puis d'un seul coup on
gagne plus rien soit tu te fais passer
de mode la nouvelle génération prend ta
place enfin il ya tellement de facteurs
qui rentrent en compte
puis je parle même pas des problèmes
d'emprunt tout ça là je comprends pas
par contre pourquoi il n'a pas bougé
sont fous parce que en fait il veut
aller cet échec est à l'échoppé l'autre
vous entende à mal suite et dames france
et 8 web après il suffit juste de bouger
son roi mais bon ils veulent ils veulent
contourner en fait il veut contourner
son roi le faire sortir de sa tanière
et après
mais après je sais pas mais en bruilhois
le faire sortir de sa tanière
en tout cas là c'est sûr que c'est lui
prend pas s'en fout il est choqué
matelas mais bon il faut aussi poussé
son pion angers 6 pour couvrir la case
h7 voit donc voilà ça c'est réglé
du coup il va bouger son full j'imagine
qu'à une question pas mal d'ailleurs sur
adblock qu'est ce que tu en penses comme
en fait depuis que je fais des des
vidéos youtube en fait arrêter
d'utiliser adblock by adobuzz
c'est bien mais enfin ça dépend pour qui
il en fait c'est sûr que pour les
youtuber il ya 60% des personnes qui
utilisent adblock donc c'est 60 % de
revenus en moins potentiellement tu vois
mais après il ya des extensions qui
permettent de gérer adblock suivant les
chaînes qu'on regarde en fait
automatiquement on rentre une liste de
chaînes et quand on va sur les chaînes
d'un youtuber qu'on aime bien et bien
d'un seul coup à deux blocs se désactive
automatiquement et ça permet donc de
bloquer les pubs de youtube eur cons on
s'en fout et de gays et de garder et
plus pour les youtuber qu'on veut
soutenir quoi ouais mais bon d'un autre
côté tu peux soutenir tout le monde
aussi ferme à ce que je pense maintenant
c'est que du monde tu regardes du
contenu au début tu sais ça doit être
gratuit tout ça mais d'un autre côté
même un mec que tu aimes pas trop il ya
quand même fait du contenu et du moment
que tu le regardes même s'atteler pas en
finale taka pas regarder tu vois ce que
je veux dire non surtout que les pubs
youtube tu peux les tu peux les appeler
après 5 secondes donc c'est pas non plus
ouais bah après il y aura quand la buse
1 c'est sûr il y en a ils en mettent
toutes les deux minutes dans leur vidéo
comme dirait mon âge mon entraîneur
murtha s'il y avait un mot que j'ai
adoré comme il n'est pas français il
n'est pas français ils étaient kazakh
mais il disait diagnostique en fait
c'est simplement le diagnostic en fait
c'est le mec mais trop de trop de pub
youtube a relancé diagnostic s'est enfin
c'est juste qu'il faut pas regarder en
fait je vais être guerrier le stick et
un regardable de base
non on a le feu mais j'adore cette
expression fin c'est son expression à
lui la personne qu'ils utilisent c'est
une expression en russe en fait en russe
en dix ans bon là qu'est ce qui se passe
tu as pioncer 3 qui est pas assez mais
qui est super bien bloqué par le food
hikaru et hikaru il peut éventuellement
voir les pions à 4 et des 5 tu vois
qu'ils peuvent faire un duo de l'amener
à cela mais bon il devrait y avoir un
échec perpétuel ou un truc j'ai du mal à
imaginer que que les blancs puisse
gagner en fait je miserais plutôt sur
les noirs si je devais miser basse et il
pousse son pion aux jusqu'en à dans le
bloc peut encore pousser l'autre mais je
me dis qu'il va y avoir des menaces de
maths je pense ça doit faire nul mais en
fait je suis trop enfin si car vous avez
les noirs les noirs gagnerez peut-être
mais là comme icare oil et blanc peut
être scellé blanc qui vont gagner
on a déjà vu cette histoire plusieurs
fois avec toi ce soir qu'est ce qu'ils
essayent de fleurs n'a par contre il
veut couvrir le mat avec sa dame elle
veut prendre le pion il peut prendre le
cas les entraîneurs sont ces trois ans
mais il n'a pas vu en fait il a juste
pas vu dame prend ces trois pas bon tu
penses rien foutu sûr il n'a pas vu en
fait c'est une gaffe il n'a pas vu c'est
pas possible sinon il aurait empêché
c'est impossible mais tu vois c'est ce
dont on parle c'est la fatigue en fait
c'est juste que tu un peu plus au coup
d'envoi temps peu plus le mec comme des
pièges tout le temps tu vois un truc un
deuxième truc un troisième truc tu
fatigues
bon allez va peut-être quand même s'en
sortir parce qu'il y avait
il ya du potentiel pour faire des échecs
et tout mais l'aspect que 14 secondes là
pour fabiano le show on essaie de le
mettre en échec leurs petits à lui
bouffent les pions ce qu'il en reste 1
est le plus bas est floue qui match
d'hommes demain le trois-mâts non je
pense que je regardais la dame le cas
parce qu'elle protège le pion 17 mois
après si la seule richesse de daumas
attend de l'assomption là bas veut il
veut cacher son roi ouais pour faire
avancer les pions
tu vois il veut regard il va couvrir le
roi hop il va le remettre à son roi est
couvert et maintenant il va essayer de
ramener il va il va essayer de bien il
vaut rien et veut lui choper le pion h4
maintenant gratos non mais attendez mais
tu vas y tu vois la vitesse à laquelle
ils changent d'idée si tu sens c'est
hyper dur à faire ça allait si dans
quand tu joues il est capable de changer
son fusil d'épaulé à une vitesse il dit
ah je vais faire ça quand j'ai faim tu
vois il a en main deux plantes rappelons
en même temps il fait ça plus vite que
n'importe qui laporte changer ok
maintenant dame j'ai cinq échecs et b 8
dam dom g5 et aaa
il est trop fort il était trop fort il
est roi c'est non mais d'insupportable
woods enfin que sa teneur mais sa mère
parce qu'il est trop fort en fait fin
c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on dise en plus
par la soirée télé noir il aurait gagné
l'aller blanc qui gagne enfin c'est un
magicien en fait ouais mais après faut
se dire que en partie longue dans la
vraie vie c'est pas un magicien oui
c'est plus important la vraie vie au
final parce que j'imagine que le tournoi
en sur internet s'est pas non plus non
mais dans la vraie vie on bbc fait la
même chose
ouais mais pourvu que ces deux parties
longues de plus importante et la plus de
mal ou la mention
j'avais cru qu'avec l'ouverture après
donc raid riptide il tue le suspense
mais tout à fait parce qu'enfin on
regarde le match ensemble depuis tout à
l'heure il n'y a aucune raison si on
regarde juste les scénarios des partis
qu'on enlève les 30 secondes à la fin de
chaque partie je pense que c'est même
fabiano qui doit être devant en fait
mais le truc c'est que hikaru dès que ça
devient hyper chaud et qu'il ya des
pièces partout emprise il règne sur
l'échiquier qua non il est insupportable
non pas parce qu'il s'ajuste en fonction
de la position quoi changer de plan
carrément de tout autour il voit très
vite en fait tu laisse traîner un petit
truc tu laisse traîner une petite
tactique quand il ya que 2 3 secondes
pour jour un coup un être humain normal
il n'a pas le temps en fait de voir le
petit truc qui sort du prisme qu'il
était en train de regarder et interviews
sont pour la force et ça c'est que tu
laisses un truc trenet qui n'a pas
vraiment rapport de base avec ce qui se
passait lui va tout de suite le voir il
va tout de suite avoir la nouvelle idée
très rapidement en fait il va pouvoir
changer d'idée très rapidement alors que
normalement tu peux le faire bompard
sinon que c'est facile à faire mais en
partie longue
quant à quand ils 13 10 minutes 15
minutes encore à la fin de la partie la
lui fait ça quand il lui reste qu'un
second c'est insupportable ça devrait
être interdit à l'euro à la de marge
d'erreur avec le toit non tu as ta pâte
a pas de marge et et était tout le temps
sous pression s'il est insupportable et
ua est le seul en finale ce dont parlait
au début le seul qui réussit à pas du
tout est sous pression c'est qu'un scène
parce que lui il fait la même chose mais
encore plus vite
c'est le seul qui a réussi à à soutenir
ce c'est cette pression psychologique et
tactique qui met tout au long de la
partie
donc en gros écart hull c'est le
deuxième plus fort en blitz quoi en tout
cas sur internet oui après en demi
finale il va affronter car yakine si
c'était à l'itie mais bon il est bien
parti pour écarts iachini les champions
du monde
en bis en titre donc là-bas nature des
carreaux un les années précédentes car
vous participez pas aux championnats du
monde officiel donc mais il y avait
magnus et carrier qui n'avait fini
devant va il avait gagné magnus avait
fini deuxième et donc je suis très très
curieux donc le championnat du monde de
blitz eu 103 +2 donc c'est la cadence
intermédiaire et je suis très curieux de
voir déjà ce que ça va donner sur le
match contre eux car on est surtout de
voir si car yakine pourra résister dans
le dans le bullet en 1 + 1 mais ça ce
serait un très très gros match on a donc
ça va être des pros de blitz qui vont
s'affronter quoi là on demi-finale pour
le moment' agri tchouk d'hongrie choo
qui l'a été trois fois champion du monde
de blitz donc c'était il ya quelques
années mais quand même il a eu trois
fois le titre il a gagné trois fois
il reste donc car yakine qui est
champion du monde en titre probablement
hikaru qui est réputé pour être le
meilleur sur internet et le quatrième en
car normalement bas ce devrait être car
la seine s'ils se qualifient donc tu
auras vraiment les quatre meilleurs
joueurs du monde en fait sans surprise
quoi après bon maxime et gris tchouk
c'est ils ont à peu près le même niveau
c'était le match le plus serré mais ça
va être chaud ça va être chaud
c'est maxime de son côté c'est pas trop
son truc le blitz si ici mais il s'est
fait éliminer par green shoots dans un
match très serré en fait ils ont perdu
il a perdu 16 13 je crois c'est un match
serré et gris tchouk bon c'était le
match vraiment 50/50 tu voyais avait pas
de favori pour ce match là merci mais il
est très très bon en lice à un des tous
meilleurs du monde aussi donc c'est le
cinquième alors en toute logique si on
doit mettre un cinquième oui plus ou
moins il est dans dance dance dans ce
niveau là en tout cas avec ces joueurs
là il ya aussi aronian en haute mer qui
pourrait être bruit je me sacrifie son
pion là parce qu'en fait si tu prends tu
vois tu es puni seront doublés faible à
long terme
les pions blancs ouais c'est plus
avantageux de sacrifier un plan pour
mettre ce pion de deux pions de
l'adversaire en double en double est si
son doublé isolés souvent oui parce
qu'ils seront seuls et y aura personne
pour les soutenir
donc tu te dis tant récupèrera 1 et puis
plus tard temps récupérer un deuxième
ok mais bon ce conseil pas de faire ça
pour le moment
pardon monsieur me viendrait pas à
l'esprit t'inquiète pas on met bientôt
stores a besoin de le faire mais pas
encore c'est encore un peu difficile le
truc c'est que tu vas le faire dans tout
un tas de situations c'est pas bon en
fait
mais bon ça te fait progresser en plus
les speech est ce nom bah ouais bon je
t'avoue que moi je comprends pas tout
pourquoi ils bouffent telle pièce ou
telle place mais on voit des stratégies
intéressantes toi que je pourrai refaire
plus tard peut-être entre la tour ouais
l'âge heureux qu'ils ramènent tout cette
pièce sur sur le roi la partie faux qui
recolle au score
d'ailleurs ces jeunes poissons j'ai
l'impression qu'il est toujours sur la
défense au début puis après ils disent
là on attaque une fois que son
adversaire a fait une erreur ou je ne
sais quoi chaque fois que je regarde des
matchs tu as toujours l'impression qu'il
est un peu moins bien et puis te fais
toujours le tour de magie mais c'est à
chaque fois que je commençais match
c'est toujours le même scénario de
partie que je vois hikaru un peu sur la
défensive fut dit ok mais là ça va
passer ça va pas passer tout ça et puis
et puis trouve quelque chose
mais je vous demande ce qu'il fait pas
tout rage quatre tours g41 justement
tour ces cinq n'ont fait et maintenant
il va ramener la tour en f3 en mêlée il
est quand même bien il a quand même un
amas de pièces sur le roi après il faut
réussir à trouver la faille et vous
ramener le cavalier ont des cinq d'heure
ça assez bien joué il a dû voir quelque
chose sur cavaliers des cinq tatev 5 qui
lui plaisait pas mais le truc après
c'est que tu commence aussi à douter un
quand tu joues tu la joues plus tu es
coup à force
ouais il ya déjà le premier truc dont tu
dont tu parlais en début de
retransmission que tu as et bien sûr le
livre de de maxime avec le fait que
quand il ya un joueur qui est plus fort
déjà un petit un petit complexe
d'infériorité tu tentes moins on sait
déjà une chose mais après quand tu es
mené au score comme ça ça vient rajouter
encore ouais ouais y'a pas mal d'aspects
ce psycho logique en fait un dans les
échecs importants
d'ailleurs il explique aussi à un moment
dans un chapitre que enfin parfois il
tente le bluff quoi il regarde si ça
marche ou pas
tu peut bluffer certains joueurs wii a
bluffé aux échecs c'est chaud quoi
enfin je veux dire c'est vraiment pas un
jeu où il ya de la chance quoi entre
guinée faut vraiment un
si voilà le mot ce que j'aime bien
justement avec les échecs c'est que je
déteste les jeux où il ya de la chance
en gros c'est vraiment un
enfin ça joue pas sur le talent du
joueur c'est vraiment la chance quoi à
la il pouvait prendre pas non non j'ai
cru qu'il voulait prendre cette voie
mais en fait c'est pas du bluff comme tu
as des mauvaises cartes ou quoi c'est
juste que tu calcules un truc comme ça
m'arrivait de le faire d'ailleurs aussi
et tu considères que la variante est
trop compliqué à calculer pour ton
adversaire parce que tu le connais bien
et que d'après ses capacités ou sa
psychologie va pas tu vois il va pas le
faire pour des raisons x ou y et donc tu
considères que tu peux jouer inclus que
toi même si tu veux dans ton calcul tu
considères pas être le meilleur coup
mais tu pense que dans la situation
donnée ça suffira en fait ouais mais
c'est rare et enduro tour dire que tu
peux pas faire ça avec des joueurs du
top 10 co mais il le faire ici justement
eux justement ils le font souvent parce
qu'ils savent que tu ailles voir va pas
jouer tel truc que tu peux jouer telle
variante parce que le mec qu'on trouvera
peut-être variante il sera pas assez
près pour faire ça c'est si si le fou
même même entre les meilleurs
d'accord mais bon faut choisir mais
c'est à proprement dire tu vois ce que
je veux dire c'est pas tu fais vraiment
un mauvais coup quoi tu vas faire un
truc que légèrement inférieur où tu
si c'est plus tu tentes ta chance ou je
sais pas c'est comme si le tennis tu
mets une petite balle tu vois au milieu
du terrain parce que tu sais que le mec
il a du mal à jouer contre ça peut être
plus plus dans cet esprit ce que tu vas
pas joints qui est censée perdre en deux
coups juste pour le plaisir
ouais ça se verra direct oui s'arrête
des trucs plus fin mais c'est quand même
du bluff dans le sens où toi tu sais que
c'est pas optimale d'ailleurs bon ça
aucun rapport mais il ya une nouvelle bd
qui est sorti l'as mois ci c'est le
joueur d'échecs je sais pas si tu as vu
de stéphane besoin que c'est ça ou
désolé si j'ai écorché son nom
où as tu sais il avait déjà fait un
livre ce monsieur est là ils ont sorti
le truc en en bd j'ai vu sa passe et je
n'avais pas du tout suivi ce que c'était
en fait est abattu en force une bd du
libre quoiqu'il de la nouvelle et bas
salaires cool enfin s'était passé aux
infos et le gars disaient que c'était un
vrai chef-d'oeuvre j'ai mis ça sur ma
liste pour le père noël
deux joueurs du top niveau en fait ça
m'intéresse moins entre guillemets je
connais un peu déjà mais autant la bdb
des voix c'est pas mal une sorte d'art
avec des cases en noir et blanc fin des
cases sur presque toutes les tous les
dessins quoi bref pas mal et l'avait dit
camelot alors avec le basilic la whey ce
nouveau tome qui sortent ils m'ont
d'ailleurs moi j'ai plus de nouvelles de
willy donc son roi il est coincé là
j'étais en train de regarder aussi riche
latence a estimé tour en ceci cela oui
menace ils menacent à et de là il l'a vu
way
et en fait ce genre de menaces et si tu
fais roye b ça tu fais comment avec les
noirs je me pose une question si le roi
revient bessette
il veut protéger la tour avec satan
c'est ce qui fait de la 6e à ok donc il
revient un peu au score trois et demi
cinq et demi et maintenant la 960 ta
partie préférée a enfin on peut pas la
rater opel
moi qui connais pas les ouvertures c'est
ce que je préfère au moins on est sur la
même longueur d'onde mais là personne ne
connaît la tenir tu te sens pas dépasser
parce que moi chaque fois on voit sur
les ouvertures
il faudrait que j'en apprennent quand
même quelques-unes pas seulement c'est
la pause à chaque matin
ouais mais tu vois je sais pas moi je
trouve que le fait d'apprendre par coeur
les échecs c'est c'est un petit côté
mois mambo à petite dose après les
ouvertures au top niveau c'est pénible 1
parce que c'est surtout de l'ordinateur
et du par coeur mais jusqu'à un certain
moment tu apprends plus des idées en
fait tu apprends pas vraiment des coûts
par kurt apprend juste d'aider des plans
à mettre en place
ouais ce qui est intéressant c'est que
du coup tu arrives à un niveau où tu vas
connaître ton plan et après tu vas
connaître le plan de l'adversaire et
donc toi ton objectif en sachant très
bien ce que lui veut faire ça va être de
l'en empêcher et lui va très bien savoir
ce que toi tu veux faire il va essayer
de temps d'empêcher aussi en fait et au
final c'est assez intéressant c'est pas
bête et méchant comme truc en fait ouais
bah après je sais pas je trouve un petit
peu plus joli et le fait de dial est pas
au talent mais en impro et de voir en
fonction mais vu que le problème c'est
que tous les autres joueurs eux d'après
mai ouverture bas je suis obligé de le
faire
enfin là que je m'y mette à un moment
donné surtout si je veux augmenter au
fur à mesure mais je pense que tu peux
arriver jusqu'à mille cinq cent
cinquante mille 600 en tout cas il ya un
youtube heures américain qui fait un peu
des échecs comme toi qui s'appelle h
certains le connaissent et qui a réussi
à monter jusqu'à 1550 3600 maisons
bloque un peu de
un moment c'est un espèce de ben ali il
a du mal à passer en fait tu m'avais dit
y'a pas longtemps tu m'avais dit ne vois
tu pourrais arriver jusqu'aux 1200 ce
serait pas mal mais maintenant tu me dis
mais maintenant tu te dis de 1500 1600
c'est beaucoup je trouve à chaque fois
moi je suis chiant je suis un homme
comblé les cordes quand je gagne une
partie en 1200 pour moi c'est tellement
beau coup de 4000 5000 6 tu peux passer
petit à petit les palais après ça ça va
pas de prendre là moi aujourd'hui long
terme ça peut être six mois un an deux
ans ouais mais à mon avis il ya bien moi
où tu es obligé d'être tendue hier plein
de livres d'avoirs d'être en club où je
ne sais quoi pour augmenter arrivé à un
certain palier qui fait c'est qu'il fait
des stream avec
avec des streamer des chèques en fait et
il apprend petit à petit en fait ils
stream avec daniel orange de
tchatche.com de temps en temps ah oui
donc qu'il soit aidé en fait non enfin
pas en escrime il lui donne un cours en
fait ils prennent d'accord parties
jouent non il joue pas il est pas du
tout hein mais mais jai stream avec eux
de temps en temps avec rennes qui l'a
fait plusieurs fois et est en fait il
lui manque des trucs c'est à petit
progresse
je suis un peu son aventure mais mais là
il bloque je ne sais pas car ça fait un
moment que j'ai pas vu stream et des
échecs mais tu sais c'est comme dans
tout quand tu commences à bloquer un
palier ça devient pénible après ça tu ça
te lasser un peu de temps en temps
est-ce qu'on peut récré se faisaient
chaque nom même si t'arrêtes tu régresse
pas vraiment ça revient après le truc
c'est que le niveau moyen il augmente un
petit peu donc tu peut régresser parfum
tu peux régressant lots par rapport aux
autres si tu veux qu'ils se dire qu'il
ya 100 ans aurait été plus fort que
maintenant quoi abbas entend via via
s'entend avec les sites arrivent contre
un mec avec les connaissances qu'on a
aujourd'hui
oui t'as pas un mec du top 10 mondial
qui résiste un mec du top 10 mondial
d'aujourd'hui
juste parce que les connaissances sont
beaucoup plus importantes aujourd'hui en
fait pas donc c'est de plus en plus
lourde à prendre les échecs en fait oui
c'est de plus en plus dur mais et a de
plus en plus de matériel pour le faire
aussi maintenant avec internet et tout
ça ouais grand cheikh qu'il lui dit
qu'il est monté rapidement sa 2000 sur
leach est-ce donc c'est un site
concurrent
tu dois connaître aussi et 2000 sur
leach s à peu près comme 1600 chercher
ce point comme il
c'est plus facile sur les chefs de fait
de personnes qui sont ou du fait du
classement que pas le même
je pense les deux en fait mais tu vas
sortir ce point comme ça tous les
meilleurs joueurs du monde qui joue
dakar mais bon moi mon niveau je le
rencontre pas donc après je passais mon
propre différence hier par là que les
bons attire les bons ouais joueurs
imagine par exemple moi je suis en train
de me taper des beats sur internet dont
je joue je joue enfin jouer contre
hikaru ça m'est arrivé j'ai déjà joué
cinq parties contre la sur internet
ah ouais ouais tu gagnes ou pas non mais
je suis écoeuré fin
et que j'ai perdu les cinq mais il y en
a une j'avais une tour de plus il m'a
fait tomber
j'étais écoeuré georges pas complètement
gagnant j'avais une tour de plus j'avais
une tour et deux pions il lui restait
deux pions c'est fini quoi mais le truc
c'est que j'avais plus de temps il m'a
fait tomber j'ai été écoeurée ça fait
tomber autant ouais il m'a joué autant
aux l'amuseur j'étais trop énervé
festive non mais arrête
c'était une joke quoi et et hikaru
nakamura tu peux tu peux pas faire ça
quand tu dis c'est pas du jeu les mecs
qui jouent autant et tout ça mais moi je
déteste ça les mecs quand je mets mes
puis qui joue autant et qui bouge
n'importe comment leur pièce mais le
plus rapidement possible ah je déteste
ça puis en général il y arrive toujours
au final je perds autant parce que j'ai
pas j'ai pas assez de maîtrise pour
mettre échec donc au final voilà bon
après les quatre autres qui n'a gagné
facilement raconte que celle où il a
gagné autant céder quatre autres il m'a
massacré et donc oui mais tu vois c'est
un peu le kiff par exemple sur moi du
coup ça me donne envie de jouer surtout
à ce point comme aussi parce que ça veut
dire qu'une fois je suis en train de
jouer puis par hasard boom hikaru il
accepte le challenge tu tapes de partie
contre hikaru c'est génial ouais tu
imagines à quelque chose actifs
c'est d'être heureux quand ça arrive moi
par exemple s'il a un jour j'arrive à
rencontrer un maximum direct je propose
une partie bon je sais que ça je connais
le déni mort forcément tu vois mes
fringues pour le kiff de jouer contre
lille ce serait dingue
j'espère qu'il accepterait non mais il a
ici tu le rencontres il accepte
évidemment mais très sympa de tu penses
qu'il accepterait de faire une partie
contre un conte moi c'est sûr en fait il
dirait quoi ça sert enfin ea c'est que
ça fait plaisir donc voit enfin c'est un
mec bien en fait c'est un mec très sympa
donc
[Musique]
des légendes a presque le même âge on
n'a que deux ans d'écart en finale lui
et moi non mais ils accepteraient c'est
sûre à 200%
ça va bien aussi d'ailleurs sur
rencontre fabien bacquet maman on fera
quelques parties mais bon c'est moins
prestigieux quoi après quand tu auras
jeu contre 6 pour ça il faut mieux que
toi toi toi tu as déjà un grand maître
national ce soit je m j'aurais m
nationale si vous demandez le titre à la
fidh faudrait que je fasse des démarches
oui mais c'est rien du tout mais tu vois
c'est pour ça il vaut mieux monter en
palier on sait rien du tout ça va
d'autres beaucoup pour moi enfin par
rapport à fabien par exemple ou quoi
c'est toi fabien est beaucoup plus fort
que moi ouais mais bon fabien il était
dans l'équipe de france aussi
malheureusement il en crète avec
l'équipe de france c'est justement les
joues toujours en équipe de france là il
a entraîneur enfin sélectionneur
d'accord il est sélectionneur en ce
moment ils en crète
normalement on devrait faire une vidéo
d'air pour parler de ça peut-être après
notre stream parlé un petit peu qui vous
explique un peu ce qu'est en train de se
passer a passé la barre et oui mais du
coup ça qui est sympa c'est de monter au
début quand tu fais tu as tu vu une fois
contre infi après comme ça c'est parce
que si tu voues directes contre maxime
en fait
bon après y'a tu vois il n'y a plus rien
qui te t'impressionne c'est fini il faut
qu'on arrive donc toi en premier après
fabien que la maxime ce soit à chaque
fois tu vois tu as un espèce de tout
voir je suis en train de masquer génial
je fais la vidéo je me bats contre le
deuxième aux joueurs de choc
le numéro 2 ne sais pas si tu auras
encore des mecs qui écriront
commentaires faut de suite patron des
mecs de ton niveau quoi je suis pas ta
qui ont écrit ça que c'était trop fort
par rapport à tes adversaires là du coup
quand ce sera maximisé crieront à
linverse oui tu t'attaques a beaucoup
trop forte par rapport à toi
sans jamais quand un parcours des
commentaires qu'ils faut que tu te bats
contre contre kevin enfin normalement
normalement les dates qu'on s'est frayé
est tous vraiment c'est bon bah
normalement et en plus ça peut tomber
sur un truc marrant parce que ça peut
tomber sur le jour le dimanche ça peut
tomber sur le jour où maxime peut se
qualifier pour pour les candidats en
fait ah ouais donc ça se peut qu'on
fasse un stream femmes en jetant
reparlerai mais si les machins on
pourrait faire un strip en direct avec
fabien et tout pour cesser de suivre ça
en direct on verra ça va être sympa j'ai
pas une connexion de folie par contre je
proviens ouais ça va suffire pour pour
envoyer du flux en direct non huawei
dans la joute de the shack quoi ça ira
je pense ouais au pire je mettrai en 480
s'offre à l'affût 250 ha ouais ouais non
non enfin moi je pensais tu voir être en
720p ou bon je tente je tente pas le
1080 se servirait à rien te sens tu peux
passer mais t'as pas une tape à une
bonne can chez toi d'ailleurs bas je
suis en pleine cambrousse - c'est si
j'ai la 4g mais après voilà moi je fais
des stream avec ma wii fit et wii fit
est ce pas j'ai 5 juin donc je peux pas
utiliser le truc pour henri à web aller
chez qui je suis à 12 euros par mois tu
as 12 euro par voix avec 50 kg 50 g
tonton tu passes ton temps parce qu'il
doit être dans le chat un mâle car oui
la gagner encore
j'ai tonton basque et dans le chat il
est passé aussi chez red hat à faire
face quand on bosse à un abonné qui a
volé un poteau et du cou du coup lui
aussi empêché raid sfr est de 12 euros
cinq ans qu'il ya un problème moi je
paye 20 euros et j'ai 5 gigas
écrit mais pourrait payer 8 euros moins
à voir les appels illimités 56 gas oil
et on va falloir que je m'y intéresse de
plus près ce ben oui oui ben carrément
m'étais chez qui bat se faire et se
faire des c s et faire normalement raide
mais c'était un rêve que j'avais pris il
ya un an tu vois puis je n'ai jamais
changé
un cesti mais son cas ça se trouve ils
ont changé leur offre de foot moi et
j'ai même pas fait gaffe 8 euros de plus
bah ouais mais c'est fantastique
non mais en fait pas forcément ils vont
pas de prévenir que maintenant tu peux
avoir pour lutter au moins 145 du cloud
que ce qu'on attend gta 5 giga pour 10
euros ya un mois ouais mais bon là
l'offre dont je te parle la gelée
président yahla cause un an et demi
heure du matin en fait forfait mais
peut-être parce que je paye plus cher
donc c'est ça je sais pas moi je peux 19
19 85 ans donc c'est le premier truc que
tu as à faire après ce stream en fait il
m'a les appeler non moi je regardais sur
le sud sur les situer les offres mais
justement avec youtube raid normalement
tu peux changer du mot moi quoi c'est
pas ça qui est pratique en plus donc
justement
mais si tu me dis qu'il ya ce genre
d'offre je vais finir ce mois là et puis
passer à l'offre 5 en juillet bon après
j'ai lu par téléphone c'est pas par le
site simon appelé ils m'ont dit voilà
mon jour un machin alors c'est pas finir
le match mais encore il ya encore des
savons encore pas mal joué à une petite
pause
tu attends derrière dépenses en valeur
c'est pas les offres sur internet mais
tu peux les appeler leur dire oui
bonjour je suis à soldats faisaient plus
vite et je vis à vis des eaux je ne
comprends pas à quoi je fais des stream
dire maxime pour les candidats j'ai pas
la kadji quoi sur l'école il ya des
youtube qui font des partenariats avec
genre orange et tout pour avoir le trucs
gratos à y en a plein qui font ça c'est
trop cheap tammet attend regarde nouveau
forfait a annoncé avec l'iphone s'est tu
pendant on pourra appeler cette vidéo
absolue un stream d'échec ce qui suit
est étonnant 30 g ou égal à 10 euros par
mois
non j'ai pu passer à côté de ça en fait
ils n'ont jamais appelé pour changer mon
truc coincé des vraies salles ou un holà
absolue gagne 10 euros par mois grâce à
un stream de ces dingues dit les mecs
qu'ils m'ont c'est sûr forcément mais
j'étais un peu con de ce que c'est sûr
qu'en un an et demi vous avez changé
leur offre quoi j'ai jamais regardé j'ai
jamais eu la curiosité de me dire tiens
peut-être qu'il ya de meilleures offres
à 20 ans il me fait marrer yd il faut
que tu appelles tu dises sur absolute
absolue vidéo il ya quelques de guitry
mec tu l'as où tu leur parles comme ça
les mecs qui vont rien comprendre
alors ils ont carrément changer leurs
prix là des langues
bah du coup voilà je me suis fait
carottes pendant deux mois
fantastique c'est peut-être le stream le
plus utile on est en train de faire dix
mecs dans le sas et regrette la e-santé
des forfaits quoi justement là devraient
nous sponsoriser on leur donne peut-être
des clients sans géo et calvin euros par
mois bugs avec ce que je paye je peux
avoir songé au vraiment besoin non mais
bon
donc voilà avec le même prix que je paye
aujourd'hui mais en fait tu peux
vraiment faire un instrument 4g du coup
avec ça même avec cinq ans a même avec
30 g ou un second se sont foutus - oui
mais en fait c'est pour ça qu'ils m'ont
appelé qui vont proposer de trucs à 12
euros du coup parce qu'ils sont dit que
sinon j'aurai un truc à 10 euros à 30
giga qu'ils allaient changer les offres
ils sont malins en fait mais bon je suis
vraiment content maintenant
et moi ils m'ont même pas appeler quand
aulas on a des vidéos ils se sont dit on
lui fait assez de vue ça va ça va du
coup je sais ce que je veux faire ce
soir
mais c'est un peu la bonne nouvelle pour
toi tu vas me faire économiser peut-être
pas je sais pas quelle forme que je
prends en tout cas tu vas me faire
augmenter des géo way plus donc tu
pourras stream études ont donc quelque
part parce que la 4g est meilleur que la
wii fit pour toi fera chez moi l'art jeu
ça après moi ça va 100 ça passe en wifi
mais la 4g une meilleure vitesse
la 4g c2c toi tu captes akadjé chez toi
ou pas outre en 3g ouais ouais je capte
akadjé mais ce que la 4g est forcément
meilleure clarifie forcément si tu as un
move et wii fit la 4g c'est de la bombe
c'est j'étais sûr de chez moi je suis en
dix-huit 18 gares d'un lot des deux
gigas en upload jet ou tout tu peux voir
ça pourtant personne speedtest.net toi
avec ton téléphone tu tu télécharges une
appli qui s'appelle speedtest et tu vas
pouvoir voir beau quand je suis en poste
alors ça peut être pas mal aussi pour
les autres live cd live
quand tu fais ça tu vois par exemple
quand je fais des live sur un jeu vidéo
je suis en même temps obligé d'utiliser
de la connexion pour ma webcam tu vois
la diffuser sur youtube en même temps à
utiliser la connexion pour jouer au jeu
tu n'y arrives pas en fait bah ouais du
coup c'est la merde
alors mais d'ailleurs puissance et faire
une chaîne de gaming va bientôt non de
faire d'ailleurs en parlant de ça
j'étais à la paris games week qui hier
et il y avait un jeu vidéo français ou
cdd et chaque que tu joues et place des
pièces d'échecs c'est kim jong-un est
d'être un des trente pas mal et ça
s'appelle people jesse j'ai pas vu mais
j'ai senti quand sa diction faisons que
de l'autre côté c'était trump est en
gros il a des missiles et tout laisser
en 3d enfin ça se laisse pas mal et
c'est un jeu développé par des
développeurs français quoi c'est plutôt
cool non et c'est sympa les contacts et
non je veux stream et pour le monde des
jeux de stratégie tu vas peut-être d'une
civilisation away sympa donc ce serait
une autre chaîne quoi complètement aimé
genre jugé fait trop d'échecs tu vois
j'ai l'impression de parler trop
d'échecs tout le temps et simple du
instants au bout d'un moment c'est un
peu frustrant fait du heurt stone jeu
d'hugo meilleurs stoppeurs stone enfin
le truc c'est que je connais un grand
maître français qui est très bon à
l'heure stone vraiment très bon il est
il était légendaire où j'ai plus comment
t'appelles ça quant à l'étoile à la fin
quand et pas des gens dehors légendaire
et en fait ils m'avaient contacté il ya
six mois il m'a dit oui à kiev
on avait parlé serait cool qu'on fasse
des strips 2h stone et tu avais dit
ouais ce serait cool et puis j'ai un peu
bolos quoi je suis jamais retournée vers
lui et en fait j'aimerais bien faire une
chaîne de gaming avec des gens tu vois
des joueurs d'échecs en fait de base
mais en fait qu'ils jouent aux jeux
vidéo quoi bas après aston moi qui aime
pas trop la chance c'est beaucoup de
chance parfois c'est pour ça que ça me
souviens trop de chance et tu vois je
préfère clash royal même s'il ya
beaucoup de chance aussi parce que j'ai
l'impression pouvoir poser les mecs où
j'ai envie alors il ya déjà un petit peu
moins de chance ça clashe royal je suis
monté à 3 203
je suis combien mois clash bryant je
vais tous les jours aussi la classe
royale
bah ouais j'ai pris goût je suis à 2008
s'en séparer mais là il ya un gros
panier entre 2008 3002 ça joue à peu
près au même niveau
ouais bah là j'essaie surtout
d'augmenter mais les cartes quoi niveau
mais du coup c'est hier qu'on pourrait
se faire un stream de deux classes
moyennes un de ces quatre cette photo
mais je vais faire une chaîne surtout il
sait faire dakar aux gens de mon clan
meta 1 dix cornes aux mots j'ai pas de
discours derrière moi je joue solo je
pourrais de non non on n'a pas de
discorde
moi j'ai pas le times ans déjà que j'ai
pas le thème pour mes vidéos mais un
discours je veux dire
absolue vidéo pas forcément à bages et
un discorde pour ma chaîne secondaires
parfois quand je fais des des live sur
world of warcraft mais vu que je joue
plus à world of wacraft depuis un mois
l'un peut un peu mort comme discorde
nous note discorde il a un peu vivant
mais ça dépend des fois tu as des mecs
qui viennent ils sont vivants et qui est
en a d'autres ouais bah ça discorde quoi
c'est qu'il faut que j'arrête j'ai aussi
fait des blagues refus en train de
préparer deux autres blogs même trois en
fait si je réussissais 3
elle était cool ton blog au maroc mais
moi ça m'a donné envie d'y aller mais tu
sais tu te jure on s'est trop amusé
c'était dingue en fait
bon après je n'aurais pas le niveau
quand même ce jeu ça quoi mais en fait
le truc faudrait que je fasse un truc
pour débutants déjà en fait on est
heureux qu'un peu de mal on s'est pas
mal débrouillé parce qu'on avait un
joueur qui n'était pas forcément enfin
on avait des niveaux qui étaient un peu
disparate on s'est bien débrouillé mais
c'est surtout comment s'est amusé
c'était juste en fait mais j'ai remarqué
ouais ils étaient tous assez âgées en
fait la plupart
moi je veux tu m'attendais à des jeunes
c'est différent c'est une super osmose
en fait qu'ils aient pas que des jeunes
tu vois ce que je veux dire ça crée une
super ambiance non c'était juste ou faux
en fait on s'est juste trop trois musées
maroc c'était très sympa je vais pas
citer déjà allés ouais je suis john y
aura des trucs à raconter mais vous pas
sur l'antenne
pas sûr donc mais c'est surtout fat qui
nous a fait marrer même pas femme sait
c'est un mythe femme aille en train de
perdre la partie au la tactique des
bills encore une tactique débile il se
prend ses quatre gardes sont rois obligé
de reculer
et du coup il perd le plonge ici c'est
la tour ouais enfin c'est qu'en vue
tactique débile c'est que c'est une
nouvelle fois c'est un petit piège à la
con quoi y'a pas d'autres mots disons
qu'il a fait une erreur une erreur
stupide
enfin stupide c'est gérard nautile le
force à faire des hits met trop de
pression en fait d'une nouvelle partie
qui n'aurait pas dû perdre non mais j'en
ai marre en fait dit car vous les
excuses - alexis 1 mais ça me tape sur
le système de voir que des matches comme
ça en fait j'en peux plus quoi c'est
vrai que c'est toujours au dernier
moment que hope retournement de
situation je suis pas si je t'avais
envoyer une vidéo de l'entraîneur de
l'équipe d'algérie de rugby non somme de
rien je t'enverrai mais en gros le mec
il est là discours d'avant match il fait
bon bain en gros ça fait 23 matches que
je suis ses lectures à l'équipe
d'algérie
on en est à 23 défaites et il en ressort
ans il commence à gueuler j'en ai plein
les couilles de perdre tu vois tu as été
un axe sud ouest mais genre le mec c'est
ça c'est 23 matches 23 défaites tu vois
il enfin il dit qui dort plus la nuit en
fait non plus quoi bah ouais c'est un
peu la même chose acquis 40 tu vois j'en
peux plus c'est toujours le même
scénario qui se répète à l'envi qu'ils
perdent changer la donne j'ai envie
qu'ils perdent pas contre magnus en plus
parce que contre manu ce come back
musical yeux aussi tout le temps tu vois
quelque part quelque part j'y perds
contre un autre qui comme lui quoi j'ai
envie qu'ils perdent contre un mec
normal en fait il est trop au dessus du
game
j'ai pas qu'ils se seraient dans youtube
gagne français du coup il car ou alors
là j'y connais rien du tout en fait
comme je vais film qui est un game
c'était des gamines de tous quand j'ai
dit que je radote parce que cette
histoire soit déjà raconté plein de fois
mais le problème c'est que alexis ne la
connaissais pas j'étais obligé de
remonter cette histoire c'est une
obligation
il ya peut-être des gens dans le chat
qui n'était pas encore au courant
non mais là tu vois c'est un peu les
mêmes positions depuis tout à l'heure
c'est une nouvelle c'est une nouvelle
berlinoise d'ailleurs tu envoies un peu
toujours les mêmes choses en fait les
mêmes sous couverture les mêmes
scénarios mais là maintenant il car où
je pense qu'il va juste est dans le
contrôle de toute façon il est plus 5
points
fondamentalement il est enfin il est
très très bien dans le match on mais
voilà il a plus de social ce faire je
pense un parce qu'il peut remonter la
fabia non c'est presque impossible en
maintenant tu veux que je te fasse rêver
je peux remonter mais vraiment pas ce
que tu m'as dit qu'ils nous fassent
rêver en fait voilà en fait tu pourras
qui gagnent toutes les parties elles à
partir de maintenant c'est ça ou alors
des connexions d'hikaru des connexions
internes tu sais pas avec eux des trucs
comme ça
bon allez on va le dos appuyé souvent
alors un volontaire pour des dossards
icaro s'il vous plaît bon alors en soit
je sais pas c'est la seule chance
non mais bon ils méritent des blagues à
pas oui bah c'est le plus fort c'est le
plus fort de toute manière monsieur
messer dans tous les sports comme ça
qu'elle attend je les récupère un truc
alors attends on peut laisser de mettre
le score bande
il ya de la musique de chez moi donc oui
là c'est une finale qui va se diriger
c'est un peu mieux pour les blancs à
cause des pions doublé en mai bâle a
clairement mais bon c'est pas ça qui va
nous faire sa magie habituel déjà ce
serait pas assez je pense pour gagner et
de toute façon ça je pense qu
objectivement ce serait nul
mais de toute façon j'ai envie de te
dire qu'est ce que ça change toute façon
il y en a tellement perdu des comme ça
grand cheikh il faut faire appel aux 18
25 ans tu jeuxvideo.com c'est les salles
qui peuvent vous sauver
soit higway bon faudrait que fabiano
qu'à une seule a pour le moment il n'a
pris pas mal des espaces allaient droit
il n'est peut-être pas si mal pour une
fois
il commence à faire froid arrive à tenir
toi c'est pas la porte non c'est pas
trop fin des votes restaurer cinq
minutes si tu veux non non ça va le
faire
une heure avant elle son camp normand
mais là il ya un petit moment de détente
pas trois heures
le truc ouais mais il dépasse à chaque
fois à cause du truc duchess d'échec 960
qui rajoute eu parce qu'il faudrait donc
en fait je toujours 3h38 le tour 3h et
3h30 depuis cette saison la saison
dernière c'est vraiment trois heures en
fait rien d'autre
et en fait je n'avais pas l'expérience
des premiers matches qu'on a fait ok ok
chaque fois je m'attends à trois heures
pour ça je me dis bon à 21h c'est bon il
va pouvoir bouger son pion là jusqu'à la
dame esquisse encore fait piéger bah oui
voilà elle peut rien faire l'un sachant
que ce tour elle peut pas les leurs ou
choqués sont rois si ferrari 3 h 3 il
peut pas faire rager d'euros achats ne
peut pas le stop avec le roi il peut pas
le stopper
c'est encore perdu c'est tellement
prévisible non voilà ce futile ce
footeux non mais ok mais t'as pas le
droit de te faire piéger comme ça comme
les y fait piéger comme un peu comme un
poussin qua non mais ok mais c'est
vraiment piéger comme un cri puis on a
peut-être marre
non mais enfin tu vois c'est ce qu'on
disait on n'a pas trop regarder cette
partie on a un peu en mode détente mais
mais tu peux pas autant craquer ton slip
t'as pas le droit
il va finir sans slip la caravane c'est
trop c'est trop
ça deviens humiliant du coup on peut
peut-être switcher de joueurs qu'on
supporte alexis tuque ont peut-être pour
l'humiliation de fabiano mais d'ailleurs
j'ai remarqué toi tu as le point de vue
de fabiano sur son échiquier moi j'ai le
point de vue du carreau depuis le début
c'est peut-être pour ça c'est plus
facile à supporter pour toi bah oui moi
j'ai l'impression de gagner à chaque
fois l'impression de me faire démolir
d'ailleurs t'as pas peur à personnaliser
son échiquier toi moi je vais j'ai mis
un beau bois être tout ça avec des
étoiles d'arrière j'ai tout
personnaliser moi non voilées les screen
le célibat c'est l'espace l'infini comme
la comme le nombre de possibilités aux
échecs que c'était au temps de jeu c'est
plus ce que c'était
autant de d'atomes qu'il ya dans le
billet vert ou je ne sais quoi
ouais possiblité de coûts à partir du
deuxième coup il y avait autant d'atomes
enfin chez lui je me rappelle plus trop
mais c'est un truc dans le genre nous
dit fabiano doit être en colère sur le
pas de la colère c'est du dépit je pense
temps peu plus
j'aimerais trop venir ont joué deux
contres hikaru tu vois genre c'est sûr
mais c'est sur la rage tue un musicien
tu vois
mais icaro moi je vais bien envie de
voir ce que ça va donner contre car
yakine quand même franchement il ya tout
le monde qui dit qu' car ou est favori
machin que contre car yakine ça va le
faire et tout ça franchement je paye
pour voir peut-être que je vais enfin
arrêter de perdre que valeant b3 la dent
tu penses à ça aussi ouais ça va faire
une fourchette mais après ça lui laisse
le plan mais bon toiture prend le pion
en c5 puis après tu menaces le fou quoi
quel problème
voilà après une menace aux soins et
danses apprises prix serait bon que ses
ouailles à oui d'accord j'avais pu aller
juste ici mais ok c'est juste du coup ça
va être encore à celui qui fait la dame
en premier quoi celui qui fait la
dernière va perdre mais je crois qu'on a
l'habitude de scénario avec toi déjà on
sait qui c'est la dernière erreur
généralement
les une expression comme ça aux échecs
celui qui fait l'avant dernière erreur
gagne
bon là il peut l'avancer ouais voilà
après l'avoir son corps ce qui peut
choquer après ouais il peut mettre son
cabinet dans un bet5 après pour le
mettront à 7
il veut passer en force de 5 à 7
non je fais pas parce que sur cavaliers
français cette saga vallée des saints
qui te clous et que tu récupères le
canal quand même
après avoir fait ce que tu peux pousser
les pions à pour essayer de faire une
dames et que lecavalier réussissent pas
à une chope et avoir ce qu'être français
ce kebbe 5 à 4 des français donc penser
cette scène la main parce que même si on
fait cai b5 que l'autre pousse à 4
je veux dire qu'on fait que les français
7 que l'autre pouces avec l'adq ont fait
que répondre 5
voilà il fait cavalier b saint caprais à
cette saison la passion partagée par
tous même il va faire cavalier 8 comme
ça si tu bouges lecavalier il te chope
le pion à la misère elle le protège plus
bohème et sur calais france et celle ci
veut faire tours détours ses cinq le
retour à huy ouais bon après soiffards
nul quoi et pas sûr parce que enfin la
question ses tours ses 104 ans et 7 à 4
peut-être c'est une des questions mais
là ou qu'il fait ça a bien joué sur tour
des huit tu veux faire cavalier français
7 et le cavalier protégera la tour balas
il fait autour de 8 mamie fait cavalier
français 7 / tour des huit mois mais
dans ce cas là son cavalier l'autre
cueille prend son courrier dans ses
carnets tu perds ta tour en des huit qui
reste en prise c'est bien eu du coup il
va peut-être la tenir autour des 5 tours
des cinq tours à huit vous bon allez un
cavalier à 7 puis voilà vous prenez
chacun votre pion et puis basta non ici
peut prendre le clonage juste faire car
ils étaient quatre en fait tu évalues de
prendre avec la tour mais tu vas voir il
va tourner baïla il a une idée derrière
la tête ou vos pires lives avec le roi
regarder il veut faire tout raciste et
aller choper le pion à 5
torah site ouais ouais mais du coup le
plan est plus protégé quoi français ça
te fait systématiquement tour à tour ses
6 alors attends qu est ce qu il est en
train de faire sur cavale et prend ses
sept tours c'est 6 à 3 allez me suis
rattrapé à faire cavalier prend 1,3 il
reviendra pas oui mais y'aura tour à 8
non je pense que à 3,7 à trois ça va
tenir ce que sur cavaliers prend 1 à 3
ont fait tour à 8
on attaque le cavalier on se dit que
vous lassez nul dans des positions comme
ça malgré les pions doublé tu vois ça il
n'y a pas assez de matériel
pourtant moi avec ce genre de deux
pièces je continue jusqu'à mon dernier
souffle
c'est drôle parce que parfois je fais
des parties où je suis carrément mené
quoi il me mène de 5 6 points mais je
continue jusqu'au bout tu vois et puis
le mec parfois il est tellement sûr de
lui de vue qu'il a cinq points d'avance
qui n'est pas concentré ou je ne sais
quoi il fait une erreur tout bête puis
au final
hop je prends ça rennes où je ne sais
quoi et du gagne et je gagne mais ça ça
arrive mais là haut niveau en fait ce
truc là pas autant évidemment mais tu
peux jouer des positions perdues
normalement et puis mais ce qui est
grave c'est qu'ils car où tu vois il
essaye même de gagner sa faim tu vois
c'est qu'elle m'a brisé à ce niveau là
c'est quand même vraiment le détruire
quoi il sait pas trop ah bon pourquoi
ils sont pas très potes même plutôt
l'inversé
ce qui place il expliqué mais je sais
vraiment pas pourquoi je ne sais pas de
cacher un truc quoi je me rappelle plus
pourquoi peut-être je n'ai jamais su je
sais qu'ils s'entendent pas forcément
très bien
j'ai essayé de gagner ça quand même ces
groupes n'ont proposé nu qui a proposé
new york regardez ces hikaru qui a
proposé la nuit
qui est-il
ça va être nul quand même parce qu'il va
aller cacher son roi et c'est nul
théorique dans le chatt sa marque et
what is in doing
ils comprennent pas qu logique entre les
deux est en fait oui quand tu vas te
cacher peut pas gagner ça c'est une
milles théoriques mais bon c'est pas la
peine de faire ça crie continue alors
que parfois ils acceptent la nulle alors
qu'ils ont les trois quarts des pièces
sur le plateau là ils n'ont plus que
quelques pions il continue jusqu'au bout
c'est étrange mais c'est comme ça l'ego
des joueurs ou je sais pas pour quelle
raison peut-être il veut laisser tourner
la montre en fait sicav ou tu vois il
est tourné la montre et ça permet qui
est moins de partir à jouer comme il a
un gros avantage au score mais bon il
n'a pas besoin de faire ça un peu
étonnant on peut prédire les coûts des
joueurs en effectuant un coup sur
l'échiquier essayer de devenir le
meilleur pronostiqueur un seul
classement on a bien fait un speech est
emmené famille s'arrêtait de commenter
pendant 10 minutes parce qu'ils jouaient
à ce truc là
il voulait absolument gagner du coup ils
disent non et moi je joue à mon jeu de
pronostics enfin regarder les parties si
vous voulez enfin fabien il pronostiqué
oui d'ailleurs hikaru il a une chaîne
youtube aussi il a ouvert une chaîne
youtube
ouais les commandes des parties de choc
commence en train de jouer c'est assez
sympa d'ailleurs c'est même très sympa
qui lancent tous leur chaîne youtube
avec maxime en fasse une aussi
il fallait bien ça lui tente pas non
fabien ça lui suffit ça lui suffit ce
qu'on fait déjà
c'est déjà bien si les joueurs
professionnels encore un il ya pas mal
de tournois de trucs à faire et tout
homme quand tu vois qu'ils carreau il a
une chaîne alors qu'il est dans le top 5
ouais c'est pas trop son truc de blitz
et sur internet
c'est pas trop sont pas trop son dada
quoi bon cette partie une nouvelle fois
un quart ayant f5 et où la tuer il donne
le camion arrive cinq pour essayer de si
tu prends avec le pion en fait d'ouvrir
la colonne j'ai pour attaquer ouais ou
les jeux des pronostics les jeux de
pronostics en fait ces deux bases sûres
sur chaise points comme quand tu te
connectes et que tu regardes une partie
des directs a directement le jeu des
pronostics en fait d'après tu as les
scores des gagnants une fois que la
partie est finie j'ai remarqué oui bon
ça sert à rien mais bon geste pour
savoir qui avait raison
enfin le plus raison non mais femme
était très heureux d'avoir gagné après
enfin bon ça me donne pas qu'il ait
gagné après mais c'est chaud quoi enfin
c'est un des mecs fort qui joue enfin
sais c'est pas un peu surtout surtout
pronostiquer sur du blitz quoi c'est
quand même pas le temps de réfléchir
des fois en fait t'as même pas le temps
de pronostiquer le coup en fait c'est ça
en fait surtout au début de partie tu
pronostique rien du tout
oui ça n'a pas forcément le temps de
pronostiquer quoi que ce soit quand même
de faire ça sur deux sur 2,15 quoi oui
non c'est trop c'est trop court entre
guillemets pour pouvoir progresser
oui mais à la fin si tu gagnes tu gagnes
de l'argent
ban ont forgé par l'impression non enfin
tu gagnes le fait leur pronostic est
confronté heureux d'avoir pronostiqué
mais à part ça ouais c'est ça en fait
mise à part ça tu pronostique un du tout
pourquoi je fais ça moi j'aurais fait
fait cavaliers en herbe six mois
maintenant au mieux protéger le plan
marshall 3 jan moi je me serais pris une
fourchette royal tueur tout bêtement
mais bon là c'est quand même assez
dangereux parce que les blancs ils ont
quand même beaucoup de pièces en attaque
peut peut-être mettre la dame en h il
met un truc c'est que sur damache 4 en
fait ce qu'il veut faire c'est faire
dame pranger cinq prises angers 2 5 et
cavalières trois échecs
ah ouais fourchette royal j'étais en
train de la regarder
c'est l'idée en fait bon bien sûr ils
les ont tous les deux vu un voilà
après si metz à tour en j80 être
problématique aussi pour lui il paraît
que cette fois ci a de l'argent à gagner
sur les pronostics que pour le match
d'aujourd'hui en fait il ya de l'argent
à gagner
dommage que fabien soit pas au courant
j'ai joué pendant tout le match ça
aurait été insupportable à y avait
vraiment de l'argent à gagner mais bon
ça peut être 100 dollars comme ça ça va
être fantastique va pas être 1000 euros
tu vois ce que je veux dire la atlas
kicker qui demande dans le château
comment améliorer son jeu contre on est
en dessous de 1500 et à captain ring qui
lui répond au dessous de 1500 tu peux
arrêter les échecs du coup tu n'arrive
jamais à dépasser le stade tu dois
arrêter les échecs en fait c'est
horrible tu peux faire en jce du trail
juste à tactique déjà ça peut suffire à
progresser de différentes affaires batwa
justement tu progresses comment victoire
et sur le chemin
bon je prouverai sont joints ou tout
simplement non je veux dire je les pas
des livres je regarde quelques-unes tu
de tes vidéos tu vois mais bon c'est
tout quoi ah par contre je fais beaucoup
en ce moment de tactique sur trois
points comme ça c'est bien non bah ouais
bon j'aime bien les petits problèmes
comme ça puis en général je les fais
quand j'ai pas beaucoup de connexions tu
vois quand je suis dans la voiture en
passagers parce que le problème quand on
va où là oh merde mais il n'avait pas vu
je pense de lui
[Musique]
menaces m'attend g7 et ça va être dur
l'amuseur voilà vraiment c'est icaro
avec les noirs donc c'est pas fait
encore ricard aurel et blanc tu vois moi
mais là il se fait avoir comme un bleu
là non ouais il a un peu déconcentré
c'est un peu trop facile maintenant
pourquoi il n'a pas mis sa dame en anjou
8 parce que la tour en général et
écroués par la d'amendé sept à huit un
car sinon ça aurait fait maths c'est
pour ça que je te dise et hikaru rien
n'est fait
ouais ensuite
tours en b 8 un an ne pardonne
bon là pourtant ils étaient en train de
mener dans le chat en fait dans la
partie s'est terminée sur le ccc car un
qui l'a emporté à ses carreaux qu'il l'a
emporté ouais alors qu'il était en train
de perdre
j'ai pas compris il ya toujours cinq
points d'écart entre les deux ça n'a pas
été sur sap a fait nul plutôt à temps
j'ai pas vu je regarde sur le truc
fabiano caruana a gagné par abandonnant
c'est fabienne mois sa sauce il avouera
ok j'ai cru que c'était l'inversé ok
mais je comprends pas le score sur le
dette en fait elle ne sera pas encore
été jointes personne n'a compris ce
qu'on va être le score officiel n'est
pas encore arrêté mais il ya bien 9,4
de plus ce que je disais du coup oui la
technique la tactique sur trois points
comme j'y joue justement quand j'ai pas
beaucoup de connexions
parce que le beau gros problème quand
toujours en voiture en passager c'est
que si un moment tu as plus de connexion
et que tu es en pleine partie d'échecs
battu la paire de simplement connexion
voilà c'est ça tout à fait du goût des
cures voiture ou dans un endroit où il
n'y a pas de connexion
je joue de la tactique eh ben j'ai
progressé bah disons que je découvre des
trucs auxquels je n'aurais jamais pensé
mais alors parfois parfois des trucs
super énervant parce que je regarde bien
il ya vraiment des trucs où il y aurait
eu deux meilleur coût possible
maintenant ils ont choisi ce que un seul
j'aurais un truc pour faire échec
soit tu mets ton fou sur une case et
lotryl échec et mat soit tu mets ta dam
sur une quasi l'échec et mat mais dans
tout dans tous les cas il est chaque
emma tu vois et banon et en a qu'un des
deux cas exceptionnel et je suis dégoûté
quand c'est comme ça tape ça bah ouais
c'est mal foutu je trouve enfin
normalement faudrait les reporter
situent les notes mettre au courant
normalement tu dois avoir les deux
solutions qui sont mises à bas il ya
toujours qu'une solution à chaque fois
moi j'ai jamais fait 1-1 tactique avec
deux solutions un tout à fait normal
c'est pas top non là où nous en sommes
dans cette partie hikaru doit être
énervé il a perdu la précédente
enfin la tension ne peut plus rattraper
quoi
c'est que le carreau il domine pas mal
fier là il a pas mal d spatiale cavale
et indécise qui s'il me son cavalier en
bo5 la peu le matin il faut 8 c'est
peut-être plus simple
ouais comme ça ça ferait une pieuvre
comme tu dis que tu veux le tu veux le
dégager en fait part d ombre qui va se
reprendre à un moment donné quoi
à la question c'est comment est-ce qu'on
tue avec les blancs en fait il veut pas
qu'ils aient car l ie 8 en fait normale
ne sont pas prévues apparemment ok il
veut il veut juste faire un road show
fait ce qu'il essayait de faire c'est
autre chose en fait tant claude fait ça
et du coup sûr qu'elle prend des six il
veut peut-être joué f6 intermédiaire en
fait faire une fourchette et tu vois
gêner les pièces des pièces noires aulas
mais encore penser un truc qu'on n'avait
pas pensé mais en fait il a accompli je
peux en paix ses cavaliers de 8
et du coup il a utilisé il a utilisé ce
temps là pour pour jouer avec 6 mais bon
une nouvelle fois tellement de trucs à
calculer genre tout reprend des ciseaux
et sa crèche sa tour
en fait non l'idée c'est que sur fion
prend des six il veut faire dame prendre
deux fous prend à eux deux est fou prend
b2 et il récupéra le fou à la fin
du coup les problèmes passe à tour c'est
pour ça que je disais qu'il y avait un
f6 était plein de possibilités de
partout et là je pense qu'il va prendre
un f6 et maintenant il va prendre à eux
de prendre deux prendre en d1
une fois et reprendre en d1 mais en fait
il a gagné un pion au cse bien vis de
l'inde donc mais tu vois les deux fous
c'est plus fort que fout cavaliers
normalement parce que dans les positions
ouvertes le fou est plus fort que le
cavalier et j'imagine que si c'était aux
blancs jouent et mettrait le fou 1,5
pour bloquer le cavalier ou 8 c'est pour
ça qu'ils bougent le cavalier direct et
maintenant moi j'ai toujours lu que en
fin de partie de chouettes avait plus de
points que les cavaliers noirs et les
poissons plus fort mais que tous deux se
passe ouais mais le truc c'est comme il
inclut en plus ils réussirent peu fourbe
et 8 à sa sanitaire désagréable bon il a
juste à bouger son plan ouais mais il va
faire x 7
ça c'est un truc typîque d'ailleurs bon
alors est ce qu'il ya un truc tactique
après deux fois 7 je sais pas mais faut
à cette vue l'idée c'est d'aller c'est
d'aller chercher les pions par derrière
en fait et tu arrives à gratter lecture
un par un
bref la même chose après on va retrouver
dans les [ __ ] couleurs opposées
et comme tu le sais les footeux couloir
reposer ça fait nul il avait un qui va
venir vous prend 1,4 et ça c'est nul
après il ya mama même avec un plan de
plus
ouais mais après y'a pas de raison de ne
pas jouer avec les noirs si tu veux
genre avec les noirs t'es ok pour jouer
puisque tu as un pion +101 tu as quand
même 6 nuls t'as pas de raison
d'accepter nul pour le moment ouais bon
joueur qui commettent une faute de quoi
tu risque rien avec les morts après tu
peux faire nous aussi faim tu pourrais
accepter nul non on va dire qu'on t'en
veux pas ne pas accepter parce que c'est
à quelqu'un qui gagne c'est toi mais bon
comme tu ne peux pas perdre et que tu
prends aucun risque et 21 août prochains
raison d'essayer un petit peu mais il
n'y a rien à faire
ça va faire nul tout seul
alors poussé le pion g et puis à voir
mais ça devrait pas mener bien loin
ouais alors essence il sort son roi puis
après il y va au talent à qui ce qu'ils
proposent
fabiano vouloir reposer et s'ils
l'acceptent pas non mais auquel il peut
jouer encore faim ils peuvent jouer la
montre mais enfin là pour l'instant
12 11 je me disais ya son temps qui
s'écoule la bizarre il a refusé nul
il reste encore 22 vie donc il va
arriver en bullet il aura un gros retard
si leur montant bullet c'est le plus
gros exploit
c'est peut-être le plus gros exploit de
l'histoire de deux échecs sur internet
si si fabiano refait son retard dans les
dents le dans la section bullet c'est
quasi impossible
là il peut encore rattraper la barre
mathématiquement oui ce qu un bullet et
encore une petite dizaine de partis en
suisse en une minute il dit ça va vite
après donc mathématiquement il peut
encore rattraper mais enfin le truc
c'est que il va avoir encore faim il va
être encore plus en difficulté en bulles
est donc normalement l'écart ne va faire
que grandir mais mathématiquement il est
bien quoi fin est bien de revenir
natation il va rester il doit rester
quatre minutes quatre parties en trois
minutes et après enfin la parole elle le
truc que tu préfères commenter les
bullet j'adore il est je comprends
tellement tout je sais que enfin j'ai
testé il ya une période où j'étais
c'était pas mal les bullet et à mon
niveau
enfin je ne sais pas comment ça se passe
dans les lots à 2000 et quelques mais en
tout cas mon niveau dans les 800 700 800
c'est du n'importe quoi c'est les
joueurs jouent au hasard tant que l'on
joue le plus rapidement possible et puis
on joue la montre quoi c'est c'est ça
les bulles est en dessous de 1000 c'est
au jeu le plus rapidement possible sans
trop savoir ce qu'on joue et on joue le
temps quoi il en général et en général
il ya jamais échec et mat
parce que c'est toujours celui qui gagne
autant donc c'est celui qui cliquent le
plus rapidement possible quoi un
avantage non pas pour pour mater la drc
juste pour avoir plus de coûts légaux
oui c'est ça des coûts qui feraient des
coups quand même
enfin pas intelligent mais pas bête non
plus tu vois c'est vraiment un monde à
part par mois au début je comprenais pas
trop la logique tu vois mais j'ai très
vite compris
puis au final ben j'ai joué j'ai joué le
jeu aussi mais bon c'est un peu débile
quoi clairement mais bon c'est un peu
comme les autres qui joue autant quoi
c'est bon c'est pour ça que j'aime pas
oui c'est pas espérer mieux mais là
c'est bon parce que fabiano il réussit
de nouveau être bien il est bien dans
toutes les parties maintenant ya un
problème sur le pion bessette tu ailles
à l'oeuf ou éclairer les qu'il faut une
double prise et sur tourbe évitera
peut-être dame f3 qui va faire une
double attaque qui va s'attaquer aux
fous f6 et aux pions bessette
il range sodome non il peut commencer
parce qu'elle prend bessette et surtout
reprend mais cette dame f3 est comme ça
il attaquera le fouet et la tour
un jeune
c'est pas mal c'est de nouveau un pion
de plus
mais le truc c'est qu'il se fait contrer
pascal karras la a5 qui attaquaient le
pion b2 protégé par l'auto en plus
et du coup si ces cavaliers sekkat
huracan qui prend b2 ce cas la tour qui
protège le cavalier depuis la tacle qui
avait lieu en même temps donc on y vient
on sait s'ils attaquent la tour mais il
va prendre de la tour ce serait mieux
comme ça après une menotte les autres
l'ont quoi d'abord il n'a pas fait parce
qu'ils auraient eu damas six ans fait
d'hommes quoi s'il avait pris le plan b
de la dame se ralliant à assise tout en
haut pour aller je pense s'attaquer aux
pièces l'adverse j'imagine
après y aurait beaucoup à calculer mes
tours b si si menaçant plus le cavalier
c6 en fait nan mais c'est bien joué et
du coup maintenant il va pouvoir prendre
le pion b2 peut-être même avec le
cavalier seul et en os la dame est en
fait c'est bien joué ce qu'il fait il va
peut-être jouer pour ces huit ne vous
fait rien vous cacher des deux qui peut
rester enfermé qui l'a fait roi h7 alors
croire je sais tu
c'est pour éviter cavaliers cet échec
qui menace est la raison pour laquelle
tour s'est vite n'était pas jouable et
maintenant à 4
c'est peut-être que le fouet recul il
veut faire peu 4 c'est bien joué ça un
même port ouais si le four eux qu'il
veut jouer le 4 mai à 5 il veut s'en
prendre à la tour au passage c'est hyper
compliqué parce qu'elle est tactique de
partout là tu vois il ya des pièces qui
sont attaqués des deux côtés de
l'échiquier qui est fou des cinq qui
s'est pas enfermé la foux je pense que
les blancs sont très bien objectivement
ce qu'ils ont un pion de plus et leurs
pièces sont plus centralisée mieux placé
mais le truc c'est qu'il a attendu la
fourchette là au prochain
cavalli en d3 terminal puis on sait de
qui veillent pour leur romance est clos
mais une erreur qui pourrait arriver
c'est c4 et cavaliers detroit
ça ça pourrait arriver comme erreur
enfin tu vois c'est le genre de gaffe
qui peuvent arriver
qui est toujours à trois il veut
peut-être faire ces quatre quand même ou
peut-être le faire tour b3 au prochain
comme ça surtout prend b3 m es tu peux
pas prendre de but à cause de la fourche
attendait 3 ok mais tout retour à 3 pts
est reçue c'est parce que tu veux faire
exactement mais un échange donc effet
ces quatre finalement il a contrôlé la
case ok mais surtout prend 1,7 c'est
quoi l'idée ce que fo prend 1,7 je
menace la tour en a trois il a l'air
sympa oui mais je comprends pas en fait
c'est juste une gaffe de fabiano en fait
je suis en train de réfléchir à ça et je
me disais avant de dire une bêtise ou
alors d'autres qui veulent y compte sur
ses deux pions pour faire un atom oak f1
ça se peut qu'ils trouvent du contrôleur
tourbe est un pion à 7 et u force ou
prend à 7 et u fera tomber cette ce que
cela suffise mais je pense pas qu'il
l'ait vu honnêtement qu'il faut qu'ils
fassent tour mais à quel point m sur
tourbe est un atout bien fou des
camaïeux food et 4 à 7
je pense tu dois faire tourner
mais à tour c'est un équipier jouer à
plusieurs
les tourbains peut-être tourbe et huit
tours b un tour baby de taza là je
mettrais un tour en 1 faisait peur à nos
cavaliers et maintenant tour c'est tu
vas me fous et tu menaces et human à ce
tour c'est cette ok ok là maintenant on
peut peut-être prendre et faire à cette
âme et il va faire tourcoing si tu
prends prend et tu fais à sète il va
faire tout reprend ses cinq apprend à
cinq à huit dames il va sacrer dans ok
mais comment est ce qu'il est capable de
jouer aussi vite et carrossée ouf c'est
plus dingue comme s'ils prévoyaient les
quads avance paris à toi l'avant c'est
hallucinant parce que là c'était le
groupe sont le plus total et il a réussi
à très vite joué et s'est même fabiano
il ya un peu de chance de s'en sortir
ferment ils avaient une meilleure
position après mais c'est dingue
c'est dingue non mais très bien joué
lors pouces
bon ça c'est comment il joue vite c'est
d'arriver à j'arrive à réfléchir en
moins de 0,5 seconde quoi je sais pas
s'il peut avoir un mini dénoncé
complètement nul mais je vois même pas
que la moindre nombreux d'une idée en
fait pour gagner parce que si tu joues
au e3 systématiquement il va prendre le
pion et après va manger l'autre camp
avec le flou et usec roi cavaliers
contre roy assaf nuls 1
pas quand ils vont fermer
mais belle défense
je cours en faire ce qui est en train de
faire il va prendre un f2 c'est
exactement le même truc que great choc
en fait
il utilise du temps pour rien pour faire
avancer le match bien en ardres le chat
qui me dit danse avec les loups
un peu cela ouais c'est juste qu'ils
font tourner la montre mais c'est pas
davantage de fabiana il peut rien y
faire puisque c'est lui qui est dominée
donc il peut pas il peut pas obliger
datant lui tu veux mais ça peut être
comme ça jusqu'à combien de temps là
normalement c'est à dire 50 coût maximum
enfin partiel à 50 coups tu peux forcer
la nulle en fait visiblement il manque
un coup donc mis k o a refusé la nulle
le [ __ ] de la haye pour recommencer à
zéro
oh le [ __ ] un acquis mais qui met cinq
sports entertainment écart au démarrage
pathétique
tiassalé 10 a crié on est reparti elle
m'a tant il a perdu le pion la wii avec
un fou ça va faire nul du coup nul du
coup il attend il attend jusqu'à 10
secondes c'est ça lui à part ça 6-6 il
va faire ça non non mais oh là là un
niveau pareil ils font ça mais c'est pas
possible c'est gris chucky qui a ouvert
la gratte la boîte de pandore il ya deux
semaines contre
et contre maxime il a fait exactement la
même chose c'était le premier à le faire
et maintenant ils vont tous faire pareil
juste en tant que personne ne l'avait
fait suer c'était un peu personne ne
voulait être le premier à le faire et
maintenant que ça a déjà été fait tout
le monde les orgueils dans le chat ça me
fait rire ont tourné le temps ouais mais
là quand même
je sais les 50 secondes que tu fais
tourner pour accepter la nul pourquoi
comme ça c'est un peu c'est pas digne
d'un grand maître international quand je
trouve ouais c'est parce qu'on t'apprend
ans les valeurs des échecs je trouve le
sport les valeurs c'est un peu comme au
judo en fait loi c'est moi qui fais dix
ans de judo
tu vois le judo c'est un art martial à
la ba à la base donc ça t'apprend pas
mal de 20,2 enfin tout un mode de vie
quoi c'est apprend à être beaucoup plus
dans la technique dans la force tout ça
enfin voilà retourner la force de son
adversaire contre lui mais dans les
championnats du monde de judo à bas
c'est plus de la lutte que du judo c'est
plus la force que la technique parce que
c'est ça qui marche en premier par aman
et donc au final c'est plus du judo
hossein sinon c'est à la wave wallace et
à la guerre contrat comme à la guerre
les résultats ça ressemble plus du tout
à nos jours au sport qu'on pratique
habituellement tu vois au final c'est
même plus le sport que tu parti qui est
coincé sais tu mets tous les moyens pour
gagner quitte à ce que ça ressemble plus
du tout aux sports quelques jours quoi
mais bon d'un autre côté pouvoir le
faire sa demande une technique
impeccable de basque il y a les valeurs
théoriques et la ganne
ouais voilà c'est sa grande chèque mais
bon mettre de côté ses valeurs pour
gagner un bon c'est un choix mais c'est
un peu dommage de trop ou alors je suis
trop nié je vais dans un monde de
bisounours mais c'est le branchement le
haut niveau c'est ça
c'est malheureux à dire parce que je
suis aussi enfin je trouve ça c'est
dommage aussi mais malheureusement c'est
comme ça c'est la guerre et puis tu sais
les six en sont arrivés là à en faire un
tel haut niveau qu'ils ont il sait aussi
parce que c'est des grands sportifs des
grands compétiteurs tu vois c'est des
qualités et des fins et une qualité
d'être un tel sportif et d'avoir
vraiment envie de gagner à chaque fois
mais ça engendre aussi des défauts quoi
bah ouais jeux surdimensionnés pour
avoir envie de faire autant d'efforts
pour devenir un sportif de très haut
niveau comme comme ces gens là en fait
en plus l'efficacité du geste plutôt que
la beauté du geste quoi ils endommagent
lui toi toi tu vois ça comme ça mais lui
va te dire oui j'avais un pion de plus
j'ai dominé la partie
j'ai tout à fait le droit de faire
tourner la pendule tu vas l'autre n'avez
qu'à voir en plus en plus à mais je dis
pas que l'appât loire mais bon cela mais
c'est moche quoi c'est un peu c'est un
peu comme les joueurs enfin les les
compétiteurs de judo qui joue la
nouvelle qui jouent en poussant
l'adversaire hors du tatami tu vois pour
gagner des points et de la lutte c'est
très moche c'est vrai c'est efficace
quand comptez quand t'es gros avec
taplin muscles et qui était pas très
technique bah tu fait que pousser ton
adversaire en du tatami et puis voilà tu
gagnes mais c'est très moche ça sera
rien
mais qui gagne voilà mais bon on gagner
comme ça tu vois c'était je sais plus
quel joueur d'échecs super connu qui
avait dit je préfère perdre une partie
super intéressante que gagner une partie
nulle pour ceux qui pratiquent
bon là il ya un truc intéressant dans
celle là c'est que tu vois les blancs
ils ont un an de plus mais ils ont un
problème à régler ces problèmes car nf3
qui est cloué et c'est pas si simple que
ça à régler bah là il peut prendre son
pion ans de saint caprais auquel le faut
prendre mais l'attrait karina valoir de
bouger ah oui j'avais pas vu le roi moi
je n'ai pas vu le roi
c'est bizarre il va falloir prendre là
oui mais bon il est protégé pour le
moment donc le truc c'est que peut-être
qu'il peut juste ne rien avoir à faire
en fait laissé son truc comme ça
de ce côté-là et juste pousser ses pions
voix est ce que c'est exactement ce que
je voulais et expliquer ce qui est en
train de se passer
donc en fait il un problème c'est qui
peut plus du tout bougé ni soro a ni son
cavalier tout et tout est bloqué mais il
peut essayer d'ignorer envoyer ses pions
se dire que la dame à un moment donné
elle devra aller gratter un pion pour
les arrêter forcément et que ça libérera
le cavalier mais ce que tu aura le temps
de faire quelque chose d'utile avec ton
cavaliers ou pas c'est une autre
question
ok il veut mettre la dame en b6 du coup
tiens c'est pas mal joué ça auquel adam
iran à huit et il jouera des saints en
fait ce qu'il veut faire c'est d'un v6
l'autre mais la dame en a 8 il veut
jouer b5 pardon puis on prend b5 et a6
et veut passer son pion à en force m
l'adamant 17 qui sera soutenue par le
pion blanc assiste donc une fois que le
pire l'entente à 1,6 et soutiendra la
dame en bessette qui déclara le cavalier
permet trois curade pousser donc en fait
c'est son plan de gains attendus tous à
toi d'accord mais après j'ai pas être
que pas vraiment eu le temps de regarder
sa vie moyen de j'imagine en tout cas
ah c'est trop dommage que son cavalier
sa liste soit clouée là parce qu'après
il ya une belle fourchette royal d'un
autre côté il aurait pas poussé le pion
aux questions faire si on prend l'option
c'est pousser l'autre pioncer ça en fait
il veut pousser les pions à fond ok
on y trouve du contre jeu de colas après
avec son roi il peut prendre le pion
pile son cavalier plus clos et non bon
bouge toujours pas c'est que les noirs
ils trouvent du contre ils ont récupéré
des pions voilà des banques l'hérault
monte carlo et encore une fois élu le
propos le pion aux quais assez bien là
il attaque en même temps le le pion f5
avec deux pièces et la tacle autre pion
là bas et ils clouent le pion à fo si tu
peux pas le pousser ouais ça c'est pas
mal de tout ça mais du coup l'autre il
va mettre son pion un an le 6 e 4 il
mesure à se faire prendre le pion à six
mois qu'il aille à cavaler point f5
imagine ouais ouais un an pion aux
quatre exact comme saïd où le cavalier
il va avoir une sacrée attaque je pense
que c'est complètement gagnant pour les
blancs
plus que de jouer de manière précise
cavaliers 2,6 n'ont même pas bons on a
eu pas mal aussi protège le pur 4 eilat
a clôturé à 6 voilà dix huit secondes
pour fabiano away du coup l'autre il
prend rover à lui prend même pas
champion
s'ils perdent et le fou en fuite qui
reste en prise à bail arrive à faire je
pense damev 6 et d'un f3 quelque chose
comme ça de 60 car on l'a plus de temps
mais bon la dame en a 5 elle va être
très mal placé ainsi va prendre le pion
ce qu elle menacera plus aucun échec
elle sera très loin de l'action
c'est pour ça qu'il a abandonné voyez
c'était c'était mort donc il reste une
partie une partie normale entre
guillemets une partie en 960 et après
les bullet
mais bon trop fort un way imbattable est
vraiment j'ai un peu me répéter mais
quand on regarde le match
fabiano il est pas si loin que ça ça met
évidemment en fin il est proche et non
en même temps mais je ne sais pas le
massacre ou quoi afin si tu regarde la
physionomie des parties pourquoi
bordeaux donne déjà un nom cette partie
va pas raconter ça devait être 1960 en
fait se sont trompés je me rappelle
d'une fois où on commentait tous les
deux piles égal il avait continué quand
même là 960 malgré ce que que les
arbitres y disait que ce n'était pas le
cas
oui oui les arts me disais que c'était
fallait pas la jouer les mecs sont
fichés total jouer la partie en fait je
m'en rappelle le jeu jusqu'au bout
évidemment il avait compté 1 je sais
plus c'était drôle en fait le score
c'est 11,50 donc c'est pas ses parents 6
l'écossé sont ce qu'ils sont fous
pranger 7 après il protège plus le pion
à f/5 la reprendre ah mais oui j'avais
pas vue l'autre cavale exact c'est juste
très marrant moi ça me fait toujours
marrer parce que j'ai vu tellement de
deux parties d'échecs normal que quand
on est au top à la gestion du poids vous
sort de ce côté se classant la caisse
est complètement le bordel dans
l'agglomération de pièces hyper
compliqué parce que c'est des positions
qui sont pas c'est pas des schémas qui
sont habituelles donc moins on a de plus
les schémas soit inhabituelle plus c'est
dur de comprendre ce qui se passe est
bon tout les orange world comprend deux
au moins c'est marrant fait le fou qui
vit on des cats la plaçant des chics et
c'est hyper rare en fait aux échecs
normaux ça arrive quasiment jamais
[Musique]
dans le chat et parle du mur avec un
tram peut construire même qu'ils sont
fous total deux parties s'est pas faite
d'échecs ça peut vite devenir n'importe
quoi sur les parties à côté c'est
souvent le cas d'ailleurs qui est
peut-être la dame en c2 et on commence à
pâques et les pions f5 et qui a
positionné très étrange ok là il n'a pas
peur de pousser le pion devant le web ce
qui pourra faire petit rock en fait avec
la règle bizarre 1960
ok les purs à fond mais il peut pas
vraiment ouvrir quoi que ce soit dans
les blancs sont forcément mieux il a
plus d'espacé c'est quand même plus
agréable mais c'est ce que je veux dire
c'est que j'aurais pris en b 600 promis
avant de faire c'est que tu as sur les
parties en fait il a tellement de
position plus que décente en fait notre
amie fabiano que tu fais là quand même
plus d'espacé bon ok c'est pas énorme
mais c'est quand même un peu mieux ben
alors on sent que fabiano domine un
petit peu le terrain en il a plu surtout
avec kiev au centre est là qui illumine
l'échiquier qui rayonne sur l'échiquier
comme tu dis il ya le centre qui s'ouvre
non c'est qu'à une bonne position là
pour pour fabiano
bon ok c'est ce qu'il va réussir à
prendre ce qui en fait s'il prend 1,4 le
cavaliere reprend 1,4 et tous se
centralise et c'est très très bien quoi
s'éprend f4 avec son cavalier
dans ce cas là je pense qu'il veut
prendre f5 je pense qu'il doit prendre
lève 4 avec son cavalier mais il ya pas
mal il ya aussi eu cinq intermédiaire ya
peut-être cinq sur canal il prend un f4
preuve quatre preneurs
il veut profiter du fait que sur puis on
prend les cinq qui est fou prend 1,5
pour faire une double attaque
roy cavaliers demande si je pense que tu
n'as qu'à roanne à peu rattrapés le son
retard pendant les bullet ça me paraît
impossible mais bon voilà c'est ce qu'il
fait là il va pousser le 5 je pense
voilà c'est ça
ah mais c'est qu'il est bloqué du coup
du coup sa part dans les tactiques et
dans le nord dans le fouillis le plus
total ouais sacrifie son truc
qu'est ce qui fait dire à ta guise
attaque le cavalier g3 wave est sûre car
il veut prendre poussé g3 cg3 direct
peut-être mais dans ce cas là il me tour
à tour en f3 quoi ah oui elle changera
jamais les pieds au moins c'est dingue
sais pas comment tu dois je sais pas
mais à première vue humain c'est rien
enfin en gros s'en fout quoi mais mais
le truc c'est que qu'il ya pas mal de
tactique avec du g3 damage de après
j'imagine qu'ils ont la supprimer le
cavale et auquel à tous défendus
non mais là à première vue ça va très
bien pour pour les blancs quand même
peut-être il peut prendre en d5 faire re
6g pas apprendre à apprendre en d5 le
problème c'est qu'il va libérer le pion
c'est qui va pousser sais pas si ça qui
est cool c'est fou à 5 bien jouer
supprime le fou il va prendre prendre il
va prendre un des cinq après normalement
fabiano n'a pas le temps de 35 qui
devrait à le kenya le pion à 7 qui tombe
ya aucune menace
je pense que pousser b6 quoique
quoique petit plus certes on prend et g3
ouais c'est ça en fait après c'est
exactement juste en train de regarder
prise à hockey du coup il prend du fou
mais attention prises angers 3 mais ça
il n'a pas vu il a pas vu à temps pour
voir fabien aure gagné par abandon
qu'est ce que nous on n'a pas vu je
comprends pourquoi prête à me ranger 3
il a gagné par abandon en fait j'ai pas
compris pourquoi il a abandonné
attention enfin parce qu'après il me
saddam en f2 lui prend le faux après ok
il y avait dame français 5 et l'idée
c'est que dans un français sans que tu
protèges la case f2 et il y avait plus
tactique après mais pourquoi il
abandonné juste en tandem pranger 3 tu
as tu prends c'est un la l'impression
qu'on à la menace est un rêve de dames
est fin et en fait d'un prince et 5 tu
menaces et à tours et fuit tu protèges
la case f2 est une menace dames c'est
cet homme des sept matches one ne veut
pas et eau pendant deux ans un abandon
est parce qu il ya vraiment matteau
prochain en fait je fais vraiment mater
parce qu'en fait surtout reprend f1 qui
serait le seul coup pour essayer de
continuer il va y avoir droit prend le
ok mais tu peux quand même faire
quelques ok mais tu fais un échec et a
pas plus mais c'est quand même tôt pour
abandonner
donc ok ok bon c'est simple comme on dit
dans le midi dans le chat on aurait pu
commencer par tour à 8
ces huit on prend ces huit dents prend
elle reprend ses huit thèmes français
s'inquiètent chez qui récupère la tour
aussi marche mais ok dame ses 5 marques
direct aussi marche les 2 les deux
marches
madame c'est simplement jugé pas compris
sur le couple qui l'avait abandonné
quand ça m à l'autre de jouer mais du
coup j'ai dû couper ici sans faille
cette tactique
moi je regardais ça en fait j'aurais
tout reprend cavaliers prendre g3 ça
c'était chaud j'arrivais pas à calculer
plus loin tu es peut-être dam des trois
quand même malgré les trois reprises
prise d'échec en échec ce marché
peut-être aussi d'ailleurs
du coup la partie une minute du coup
parti une minute et que +5 pour icare où
tu étais un peu remonté quand même
caruana
ok ils sentent que yahoo il ait voulu
faire petit rock mais en fait ils
avaient bougé sa cour au début de la
partie
il était revenu sur la case de départ et
c'est plus pour ça qu'ils pouvaient par
ok non parce que moi ici on a parti de
me demander pourquoi il n'avait pas fait
de tir hoc
ok mais ça c'était hyper dur de s'en
rappeler que les bouffées sa tour et ça
ça joue sur toute la partie
en fait je pense que oui je pense qu'il
a voulu faire
c'est pas exactement où ok c'est parti
pour les bullet n'ont pas fait de grosse
pause
ça aussi c'est un truc que je
comprendrai jamais y'a jamais les le les
pauses ne sont jamais dû même de la même
durée en fait je comprends pas trop
comment sait on du système des pauses
marche donc à trois points d'écart de
cinq ans d'écart pardon façon va être
tout de suite fixé à l'ex eeci caruana
résiste au début dans les deux trois
premières parties ça veut dire qu'il y
aura une microscopique chance il perd
les deux premières le match est déjà
terminée vous voyez tout de suite fixé
au george pas suivre trop vite
bon alors cette position qu est ce que
ça donne matériellement on va juste
compter les pièces un pion de plus pour
hikaru père de fou pour hikaru
d'ailleurs j'ai pas compris pourquoi il
a pas pris son pion à eux cinq avec la
tour gratos et voulait pas prendre 4 5
ok mais là il en train de prendre
je pense que c'est suicidaire là ce
qu'ils entendent faire
je pense qu'il a juste prendre 4 5
maintenant et les deux font juste régné
en maître sur l'échiquier comme ça ok 5
maintenant
bon ok il veut pousser les pions passé
lié mais quand même la perte de fou
c'est quand même hyper fort prend là ils
sont tous au milieu la nuit ça c'est ce
qui s'appelle vraiment réunionnais
contrôle l'échiquier juste
pareil que prendre le pion ans et non
avec les noirs c'est pousser ses pions
mais fut stoppée hier le fou qui varient
vance est ce un coup pour coup une bonne
champions là ils attaquent la tour avec
le fou le fou des quatre attaques et la
tour à wels découvrant ok là il la
donnait là la regarder avec les fouilles
un réseau de matelas l aller les noirs à
mon avis on m'a t il va y avoir foucher
six tours âge 7 et toura suite matt plus
aucun plan qui se protège moi où j'ai
six ou sept tours at 8 mars était
imparable
ça faisait mal du couloir bon c'est déjà
un point pris car ou cevital et encore
c'est incroyable et encore tu as la
latence d'internet
on dirait que ils sont au courant de
quel mouvement va faire l'adversaire à
mais souvent tu sais en fait je sais
comment ils font bon bah ça fait déjà un
fond plus pourris karume la position est
un peu bizarre
je détesterais de la position qu'il avec
les noirs mais le truc c'est qu'il ya où
il voit tout tellement vite que
finalement il s'en fiche totale en fait
nettement enfin d'avoir une position
très désordonnée sarreguemines seconde
là c'est pas possible
il avait prévenu il savait qu'il allait
prendre
mais dans ce cas là si tu prêt mauvais
que l'adversaire fait pas le mouvement
que tu avais prévu t'es dans la merde
ouais mais si c'est un mouvement de
prise en fait il reste la pièce a fait
coup illégal pour toi et donc ça va ça à
nu le jeu sans aucun doute qu'ils se
sont fait avoir sur des trucs comme ça
mais après ils prêts mauvais au final
c'était pas le coût prévu
en fait c'était dégoûtant ah bon je fais
tout en prêt mais comment tu fais pour
prévenir ces coins de touche
il faut que tu dans les préférences sur
fnac.com que tu dis que tu que tu es la
possibilité de faire le prénom en fait
qu'un jeu faut que tu ailles dans les
préférences faire un prêt move ou sait
plus comment s'appelle en france mais en
gros il faut il faut l'accepter après il
suffit juste de faire comme si tu viens
tu peux faire un truc encore plus badass
et tu peux faire multi-prêts vous à peu
près move et plein de quoi la fois où ça
tu enchaînes les cours pour une
ouverture ce peuple nomade quoi mais
après c'est dangereux
tu peux tu mets très mouvant n'avance
plus tu as de chances
que des coûts enfin qu' un coût qui te
bat en fait entre-temps quoi ça assez
dangereux mais ça s'utilise surtout sa
multi primove contient plus de pièces
sur l'échiquier presque plus de pièces
ou là ok il ya un gros enchaînement
tactique aux faux non loin d'eux non
mais là le truc c'est que ces écarts ou
qui restent avec un film plus et ses
hits yahoo qui va l'emporter quand une
nouvelle fois
l adoption pas assez lié aux fourchettes
non non cour intermédiaire mais il va
monter le roi tu vas arriver à monter le
roi il va protéger son curé à faire
rager quatre semaines on commence par ça
et maintenant voyager 4 sur moi tous la
pousse de partout il montre le cavaly va
monter le roi bon tu avais dit on allait
savoir avec les deux premières parties
si fabiano avait la moindre chance je
crois que t'as vu ta réponse
il semblerait attention les favoris et
gagne à chaque fois j'ai l'impression
sans surprise en fait il ya tellement de
partie que c'est c'est d'autant de
plusieurs de faire une surprise en fait
ouais c'est comme la stat et c'était
quoi c'est exactement ça c'est que
imagine c'est comme vous tous et pas
dans n'importe quel sport s'il vient de
faire un match aller retour de viser 20
ans 25 matchs et aurait besoin ce soir
surprise en fait plus tu rajoutes de
match quand il ya des surprises
s'effacer mathématiques
oui tout à fait du coup là pour la peine
c'est pour ça que c'est mieux de
toujours faire des sondages avec le plus
de personnes possible parce que la dame
la dame de fabiano mais c'est tellement
magicien bullet je me demande ce qui se
passe sur tarn de great man je sais pas
mais je sais qu'il ya quelque chose ça
c'est moi aussi qui fatigué je vois plus
il ya un truc ça aide à bedous qui
m'entourent bien quand même
ce qui va réussir à les mater
apparemment tu as oublié le compte à
rebours compte à rebours est là ok mais
cette partie aurait jamais dû s'en
sortir ma carrière ça je sais pas s'il
va s'en sortir mais sans voix est trop
mal depuis le début il reste quand même
très très mal encore dans moquer mais là
c'est mort
mais disons qu'il a un peu fantasque
aussi parce que quand il a un gros
avantage en fait au score tu sens qui
jouent moins sérieux tu vois qu'il
laisse filer des points entre guillemets
un peu comme maxime avec le jeune joueur
la dernière fois sauf que le truc c'est
que ça lui coûte contre contre des mecs
comme magnus parce que tu sens qu'il est
- il ya moins la capacité de rester à
fond surtout le match en fait foi sa
première fois que j'aurai en échec et
mat j'ai l'impression à chaque fois ils
sont jamais arrivées oseo à l'échec et
mat
ça va être le premier échec et mat que
je vois normalement avant moi j'aime
bien avoir un échec et mat
ce que je vois pas forcément aussi loin
que donc bien savoir le dénouement quoi
qu'est 7 13
est ce que n'a qu'à va terminer avec le
triple de points de fabiano 18,6 enfin
même la même bulle est bon les premières
particules est cajon à gagny mais encore
une fois il n'est pas si mal dans les
ouvertures il a plutôt des bonnes
positions là il a encore pas mal c'est
vraiment pas le massacre auquel on
aurait pu s'attendre presse de shangla
ça s'est vraiment joué sur deux trois
petits détails en fait ça c'est pas des
petits détails dans le sens où ok
c'était les moments les plus importants
mais tu vois c'est vraiment comme fish
est pas moins un match de foot où tu
aurais eu des occases et qu'il a un
meilleur buteur qui les met au fond ou
mais je n'étais pas là ce n'était pas du
tout un massacre mais pas du tout
beaucoup de parties serrées
mais finalement vraiment se joue par
exemple ce match
en me dit qu'il a six points en un an il
a sept points il a sept points le truc
le truc au dessus c'est le score
officiel la mauvaise partie l'ont-ils
ans ils ont réussi à la virée
bon mais l'a finalement hikaru il va
être mieux parce que son cavalier plus
fort que le fou tu vois non maman même
en fin de partie
tu vois tous les pions blancs ils sont
sur blanc et le fou il fait double
emploi avec avec les pièces il avait pas
d'une grande utilité
inutile c'est pour ça qu'ils le donnent
même au prix d'un pion et c'est pour ça
que le feu prend pas les quarts où il
veut juste échangé les dames et
maintenant il va les gagner le pion b3
et il va passer le pion à donc là ça va
être encore une victoire d'hikaru c'est
fini
c'est fini
boum si je prends deux cavaliers le pion
fils adam feeney voit donc la seule
manquait un peu plus de toi rattraper
sur les deux premières parties s'il
avait gagné les deux premières on aurait
pu se dire que le car aurait peut-être
une baisse de régime ou quoi là elle est
là il a une semie baisse de régime
c'est la fin des haricots pour fabiano
difficile
c'est vraiment un bestiau un regard où
on peut être l'effort des trois rapide
il est trop il est trop bon
j'imagine même pas le quotient
intellectuel di caro bat pas forcément
choisir tu peux être bon dans un domaine
est nul dans tous les autres ouais mais
tu as des mecs
comment on dit déjà des autistes qui
sont hyper fort en maths qui défonce
tout le monde en maths mais a dans tous
les autres domaines ils sont ils sont
carrément martin l'a quand même la
vitesse de penser ce que tu as tu peux
être bon aux échecs par un entraînement
même devenir bon en bullet ou quoi tu
vois pas ce que tu es très entraînés tu
joues beaucoup et par habitude mais là
c'est pareil quand même
enfin ça me paraît juste mystique en
fait sa vitesse de penser c'est parce
qu'il a dans le cerveau en fait là c'est
super bien joué puisque le fou bessin
qui contrôle la case 8 et du coup les
blancs ils peuvent pas contre et
l'accolade donc c'est une horreur il va
mettre la tour en russie parce qu'il va
faire il peut pas parce quelqu'un qui
vient mais il ya une grosse vitesse
fabien il trouve un peu de contrôle se
faire enfoncer par dame 6
je roi g8 et adam prend g6 et il ya un
match horrible
il va lui faire dame aussi dans le bon
tempo prochain comme ça il y aura plus
d'âme 1 dames 5 échec pourrait changer
d'âme ok mais bien joué mais c'est comme
ça même s'ils s'y défend sérieux je ne
voyais pas aussi fort un fabiano il sort
des défenses de puteaux là ça va suffire
mais voilà dans tous les cas il ya perdu
là le match oui cette partie mais faire
parler qui est hyper résistant
mais bon on a failli faire défoncer
temps là n'est pas la question
ce n'est qu'une question d'honneur avec
8 secondes ça va être de 1,5 seconde tu
gagnes combien de temps à chaque courant
boulotte 0 non une seconde après pas
différente forme de bulle est parfois
avec fab d'ailleurs on s'amusait à
calculer si tu avais mathématiquement
gagner le match en arrêtant de jouer en
fait tu sais genre en se disant une
minute c'était une partie puisque tu
pouvais ne pas jouer du tout et perdre
la partie
tapas dépenses admises et donc on s'est
amusé à compter
donc là il resterait théoriquement 14
parties si tu ne joues pas et il a que
sept points d'avancé
donc il n'a pas encore mathématiquement
gagner un fauconnier plus trop
d'intérêts à savoir à quel moment tu
vois ce serait mathématiquement gagner
si tu te lever
on reparle de cuite ou savez si je
disais ça c'était une manière de parler
je parlais pas forcément du quotient
intellectuel du maire c'est pas parce
que je veux dire enfin je m'en fiche en
fait complètement
c'était dans le sens enfin je sais pas à
fin juin enfin vous trouviez ça j'ai
passé les gens au lieu de chat ne trouve
pas juste carrément dingue la vitesse à
laquelle il réfléchit en fait fin moi ça
me fascine perso mais je trouve ça
fantastique en fait mais je passais dans
le chat ils ont eus m'ont pas l'air non
plus impressionner impressionné
je pensais juste le fait que je joue aux
échecs toute ma vie et de voir ma
médiocrité par rapport à la vitesse de
calcul du mec samassa ma lucide en fait
ce pas horrible comme sensation c'est le
désir de se dire que tu t entraînés à
toute ta vie est quand même tu as des
mecs qui te dépasse un dernier mot oui
surtout qui tenait pas ce pas de deux
centimètres il dépasse d'un mètre trente
quoi ouais c'est ça non c'est plutôt
génial ah bon parce que tu vois d'un
côté tu dis bon ok je suis complètement
nulle par rapport à lui ou machin face à
lui sinon machin et d'un autre côté tu
te dis ouah tu vois enfin il ya beaucoup
de il ya beaucoup de moyens de
progresser tu vois ce que je veux dire
c'est rassurant aussi et puis de se dire
que tu as des êtres humains qui sont
beaucoup plus intelligent que toi donc
c'est pas mal quoi tant mieux puisque du
coup ils sont pas feintes en a dans tous
les domaines qui ont l'intelligence di
caro du coup c'est plutôt cool de dire
qu'il ya des êtres humains qui ont une
intelligence aussi remarquable en fait
ouais
dans ce jeu prend plutôt dans ce sens
afin je suis plutôt un peu émerveillé
cieux par sa vitesse de calcul
évidemment si je joue contre lui je vais
passer mon temps à me plaindre et à être
très énervé machin et tout mais quand je
regarde ça de l'extérieur enfin je me
dis plus tôt on a des gens doués quoi ça
c'est plutôt sympa
oula a
à temps parce que ça normalement c'est
nul mais normalement il va la jouer
hikaru parce qu'il va jouer la montre sa
cellule théorique ça va rentrer dans une
position que là bas la position de
philidor mais normalement il a tous les
droits de fabiano qui a refusé de faire
annuler trois clics à fabienne il en a
marre du bullet
du coup il veut la jouer le plus
longtemps possible malgré l'option de
moins à mon tout ça pour dire que c'est
assez assez magistrale
ouais mais bon
enfin le pire ouest t'imagines dont tu
te fais battre parlera par un enfant ou
un truc comme ça alors que je rentrais
de toute ta vie
arrivé le tourisme ça c'est sûr les
gamins c'est chiant mais bon après quand
j'étais gamin il m'est arrivé assez
souvent de battre des adultes même très
souvent même gamin j'ai battu des grands
maîtres ou quoi enfin j'imagine pour eux
c'était très pénible aussi c'est un
juste retour des choses et du coup ça
veut dire que le gamin les plus fins il
a un talent quoi parce qu'il n'a pas pu
apprendre tout ce que tu as appris non
mais bon après
moi je suis plus du tout entraîné aussi
un donc ça se peut que je calcule moins
vite qu'avant mais mais du coup on fait
quand tu es gamin tu es tu calcules
quand même plus vite un parent cela
rappelle quand j'étais gamin ce calcul
est vraiment vite par rapport à
maintenant c'était ça faisait une grosse
différence
ce à partir de quel âge que tu commences
à perdre en performance moi quand j'ai
arrêté de jouer en fait
du coup j'ai du mal à dire si c'est une
question mais je pense à partir de la
trentaine ah ouais comme comme le sport
normaux en fait ouais mais bon des gars
comme ils s'appellent il a attendu
jusqu'à la fin c'est dingue
des gars comme kasparov tout ça et joue
encore mais appris que j'ai vu là qu'il
est ils avaient lancé des masterclass là
j'ai vu la vidéo
ouais alors pas mal ont par contre s'ils
sont en anglais c'est moins bien
c'est en anglais ben justement
à
échanges
bon alors maintenant on va refaire notre
truc mathématique non mais en fait y'a
pas sept points de détail à huit points
il ya huit points d'écart pardon donc
huits points d'écart
en fait là mathématiquement vu qu'il
reçoit il reste il resterait sept
minutes cette partie plus le 960 qui se
rajoute au dessus donc mathématiquement
faudrait qu'il joue quelques coups en
fait dans chaque partie il a plus ou
moins gagné déjà mathématiquement ce qui
verrait le truc le plus important en
fait avait fait avec fabien la con ça
n'a plus aucun intérêt on ne fait que de
parler de savate à chaque fois je sais
que ça va c'est aussi débile mais bon ça
nous amusant mais je sais pas pourquoi
ça nous fait marrer en fait parce qu'on
aimerait trop tu sais comme au basket
genre le mec il s'en fiche tu vois il
veut gagner fusent d'un point ils
calculent mathématiquement ils ne
bougent plus une pièce sauf qu'à trop
drôle c'était comme quoi ils ont les 24
secondes au genre il reste une minute tu
t'en fiches super labatut ne tente même
pas un shoot à la limite tu laisses à
bas la loterie mais un pagne et on a
rien à faire du coup l'autre équipe est
obligée de faire une faute et tout ça
mais genre dans l'esprit tu vois ça nous
rappelle un peu ça ça nous fait marrer
encore une fois c'est pas très fair play
vu que tu vois great flu qu'il a lancé
ce truc là de faire le truc pas fair
play du coup on voudrait mettre le truc
du non fair play à son paroxysme je ne
voulais plus un seul coup après problème
c'est que si tout le monde s'y met on
n'a plus fini tu as vécu personnes deux
jours et ce serait génial c'est ça
serait fantastique
ce serait fantastique selon toi ce
serait dommage complètement
extraterrestres ou tu as un mec partir
pendant une heure et demie pour une
raison x ou y ça ne joue plus en soi
c'est vrai qu'ils pointent en plus mais
bon mais bon je pense que les sponsors
il serait le pas trop d'accord mais là
on est en train de se rapprocher de la
victoire mathématiques et là on est en
victoire mathématiques saï saï grand
cheikh après il faudra légiférer c'est
vrai après faudra créer une règle pour
l'empêcher fin ça peut aller très haut
comment tu peux empêcher seule quoi
change la règle du tournoi et tout mais
là je pense que fabienne quoique
peut-être se prendre un échec
perpétuelle de l'autre côté c'est du
vent ils gagnent du temps par rapport à
sa victoire mathématiques
c'est pas ça là je pense que les
carottes sont cuites pour hikaru all à 2
da bon là il va chercher la balle et
économise du temps quelque part lui
aussi fait la plainte et le calcul la
victoire théorie chacun matelas après un
dommage aux prochains à chaque et
matelas s'il ne met pas le choc
voilà du coup il va faire chier tout le
monde a choqué matelas au prochain c'est
le vice du truc quoi c'est pour ça que
d'un coup qu'est ce qui peut faire ne
peut pas faire grand chose maintenant
mais là il va attendre et on va jouer
encore un coup il va attendre à
yamachiche chaque seconde compte quoi il
va jusqu'à donc alors d'alger 10 mais tu
vois lui aussi regarde le temps qui
reste est celui ci dit oui je regarde le
stream français de blitz traîné
absolvent et je sais qu'il me manque un
peu de temps pour ce dogme bernhard
eisel mais surtout qu'il a déjà gagné le
match si tu veux donc en fait si la
panne n'a pas besoin de le faire
ça se sente chercher quoi c'est ça quand
je dis ça mais pas trop bon car mon avis
c'est génial absolument pas ça ne nous
accueillons embêter nous en fait
spectateurs et son adversaire et tout ça
mais ça n'avait aucun intérêt
après je sais pas si c'est dans la
culture des échecs des métros l'ailé à
ce point là même dix ans qu'on a un peu
trop loin maintenant
là je le vois dans le chatt ouais mais
après je ne sais pas s'il a un haut
niveau c'est exact c'est aussi le cas ou
pas là ça c'est joli ce qui fait surtout
prend des 4 je veux faire tout reprend
h4 puis on prend h quatre cahiers pour
faire peut-être front des quatre pieds
et prend des katas me prends des 4
comprend efficace et sûr que l'on prend
en filature adam g 4 pour venir mater en
jésus en force
c'est ce qu'on va voir maintenant tu
empruntes 4 boom et si tu prends la tour
il y avait il y avait il y avait d'un
musée 4 ans qu'elle va faire tout
reprend il peut faire dame prend aussi
avec un petit échec perpétuelle du coup
si prendre la dame ça lui permet encore
way du coup il est obligé de faire plus
on prend et là maintenant il va pouvoir
faire nul mais comme c'est un nul part
perpétuel et qui le fait comme il veut
il peut laisser tourner la pendule
heures c'est génial afssa le bcsa le
meilleur moment du match suite en rend
pas compte
oh non c'est pas cool il est là le kiff
[Rires]
absalon ps battue dit les mecs cd grand
maître international ils font dans le
top sera qui sont censés représenter les
valeurs des échecs et les mecs qui sont
riches font ça quoi olala sommes samedi
good presque du doigt la fantastique
ça me fait trop mal quand les gens dans
le plus à ces trolls de niveau 50 sa
fiat aura quelque chose à raconter
devant boulot à la misère moi je serais
pas quoi je voudrais même pas faire ça
mon niveau quoi
des gens qui disent qu'il ya roux
dédicace à blé du stream tu vois il sent
que ça me fait marrer
bon ben notre truc de mathématiques du
coup c'est pas si idiot de victoires
mathématiques ben apparemment tepa le
soleil y penser tiens ça se fait une
anecdote à raconter qui pourra faire une
vidéo
enfin c'est pas toi qui les fait c'est
en toc mais mes chers non abonnement sur
la chaîne tyc arrive à cause de ça j'ai
jeté un coup d'oeil à quoi ça ressemble
c'est là cette vidéo c'est pas mal
absolut est innocent c'est pour ça
nombre moi c'est juste que j'aime jouer
aux échecs quoi j'aime jouer aux échecs
pour les échecs pas pour gagner quoi
or et moi j'ai toujours été clair là
dessus je joue aux échecs pour pour
gagner mais juste pour le plaisir de
jouer aux échecs
donc ça viendrait pas de moi de faire ce
genre de truc tu vois je trouve que
c'est marrant à regarder de l'extérieur
j'ai lu candide de la culture a encore
dit me rappelle j'ai eu aussi c'était
tellement c'était pato pas mais moi ce
que ce qui me faisait toujours héros au
collège enfin dans ce cas au lycée que
je disais qu'en guise et c'est lé prof
de français qui étaient à fond dans le
truc tu vois chaque phrase
selon les profs de français l'auteur il
avait vu ce site centric ça se tente
d'essence disait avec des potes mais en
fait le mec ça semble il a écrit ça
comme ça puis après les profs de
français ils voient tout un truc alors
que le mec il a juste écrit une phrase
au hasard tu sais
je me rappelle le prof avait dit oui
mais peut-être qu'inconsciemment c'est
ce qu'il a voulu dire machin tu vois or
il pas alerté dans des délires à chaque
fois mes propres france est l'amie
talent mot ici pas trop fait ça at-elle
signification way où il avait juste
besoin d'une rime et puis basta qua non
mais bon ça c'est comme par contemporain
- 16 ans en fait le mec qui peu chier
sur un tableau que tu en auras toujours
pour dire à ses oeuvres d'art voilà
aubry s'est fait prendre sa tour
bêtement la whey l'avait pas vue là il a
vu que j'avais gagné mathématiquement
alive une partie qui ne devrait pas
jouer je pense je pense que l'admirer
pas c'est moi qui aie 21h51 fait quatre
heures la font d'armand ces mêmes trois
heures [ __ ] moi qui me disaient 'oh
c'est cool je vais pouvoir manger plutôt
à 21h à 22h en il toujours pas super le
rouge et le noir toujours toujours plus
court que les misérables
j'ai réussi j'ai pas réussi à tout
éviter de lire mais j'ai tenté à chaque
fois j'ai tenté tout le temps d'éviter
de dire ah non mais c'est à partir de
960 c'est moi qui suis complètement à la
rue du coup ça dort là c'est juste que
les atours et 26e sont mal placés c'est
1968 je lisais le chat jeu des plus de
banc sinon un truc mathématiques absolue
avec son bol de fruits secs mais il me
manque mon bol de fruits siècle non mais
c'est la dernière en fait ils se sont
par 160
franchitti n'a jamais réussi dire
germinal après des vous convient et bien
aimé après faut enfin genre camus
j'aimais bien perso l'étranger la peste
le meilleur des mondes tu l'as lu ou pas
n'ont pas mal ça ben kargbo a gagné la
dernière et donc on finit sur quel score
le meilleur des mondes
alors le meilleur des mondes il donne
combien cette baisse 17 10 bat assez
honnête 1 franchement
ouais bah ouais c'est bien c'est pas
fait écraser écrasé qua non eh ben pour
la demi-finale cardiaque il n'a qu'à
murat moi je donne car yaqing gagnant je
vais mettre tous le tchat ados
j'en ai rien à faire on va vous défoncer
crédit g pas si on sera avec toi
absolvent j'ai même pas si ça tombera
pendant que lui fut chez toi leur même
peut-être un match je ne sais pas on
verra bien on verra le site j'ai lu
d'ailleurs de corneille j'avais même
après un passage par coeur à l'école
pour le bac de français je ne sais plus
quoi bon bah du coup
alexis je pense qu'il est temps de
laisser nos auditeurs et d'aller dîner
ouais il serait temps à 22h c'est ce
qu'on a envie de faire
je manque de sucre ouais bah on était
quoi on était 200 la wii ce sens c'est
pas mal parce qu'il ya des gros tournant
en ce moment en france c'est les
vacances et donc il ya beaucoup de
joueurs qui sont et d'auditeurs
potentiels qui sont en tournant ce ok
bah merci aux deux cents personnes qui
nous ont qui nous ont suivis jusqu'au
bout mais c'était cool avec le chat qui
tarde à ces actifs qui aimait bien trop
les de ce que je vois et puis bon bah à
très bientôt tout le monde je sais pas
quand est-ce qu'on se reverra sur le
stream bien normalement demi finales et
finale qui approche envers ouais ouais
ça pourrait être cool on pourrait faire
un truc avec tout le monde quoi pour la
finale marrant ah ouais ça pourrait le
drôle
pardon je sais pas c'est ta connexion se
porterait mais bon installer la fibre
chez moi normalement c'est pour ça que
je dis ça en fait
adacore sont venus en fait il ya trois
jours mais ils sont venus
ils ont vu mais ils n'ont pas vaincu ils
m'ont dit non il faut qu'on revienne à 2
parce que c'est très compliqué
d'installer chez vous je sais pas il
faudrait prendre des échelles j'ai rien
compris mais une histoire d'échelle en
fait il faut des échelles pour installer
la fibre chez moi ça sent la appris à
d'accord et donc quand j'aurai la fibre
furet sur dix 60
enfin voilà ça ça va changer ta vie tu
vas voir quand tu vois quand tu veuilles
plaute des vidéos en quelques minutes
quand tu vas te téléchargé des films
illégalement bien sûr en quelques mois
mais non mais des vidéos qui fait du
montage ah ouais quand elle youtuber ça
change la vie
moi j'aimerais tellement avoir la fibre
voilà la dernière dernière vidéo que
j'ai pas encore mises en ligne c'est un
12 questions qui dure une heure
quarante-cinq lui claude ça m'a pris
vas-y d'il ya dix ans nombreux cas à moi
ça m'a pris plus de 40 oeuvres
c'est à dire laisser les laisser l'ordi
a tourné pendant 40 heures bien sûr
ouais ouais mais j'aime j'aime pas trop
ce truc là
oui parce que je me dis ça ce sont bien
franck sait pas à quoi
inconsciemment je me dis wow ya
peut-être une couille si tu veux si tu
le coupe en plein milieu mais bon moi vu
que la vidéo de 1h45 durée enfin été en
60fps 1080p
elle faisait douze géo quoi donc mais
moi je suis amoureux de 60 ce que j'ai
vu quand j'ai fait le blog j'ai eu plein
de trucs et en fait pour une raison x ou
y
il ya des gens qui sont amoureux you 60
fps comme toi et à d'autres gens qui
disent que le 30 ans fait ça donne une
impression plus réaliste de l'image en
fait
c'est pas moi j'ai juste l'impression
qu'en 67 beaucoup plus nette pression
car dans la vie ouais mais je sais pas
moi j'ai la même impression de toi en
fait de base j'ai la même impression
jugé lui cette opinion qui m'a paru un
peu étrange mais du coup bon très bien
du coup on se quitte sur sa voie salut
tout le monde